so that was it I was in I thought I'm
gonna be an armed robber I I was doing
all sorts of stuff obviously selling
drugs and I can just carry on committing
crime in Europe I looked round and you
could see this tsunami of officers
running towards me I think I kept saying
I'm not going back to prison and in that
brief moment I was fully prepared to die
to try to get away from him
and he said Mr McAvoy I believe you will
always pose a risk to the public
and I believe the public will always
need protection from you he said I'm
giving you a life sentence
and I'm in this prison and I'm like I
don't want this anymore I want to let go
of it I don't want to be living this
existence
I was so lucky that I went down the
prison gym and there was a prisoner on
an indoor round machine and I thought
you know what I've never been on a ram
through my life so I did it and within
like 18 months I set three world records
and eight British records
I I regret what I did but I don't regret
going to prison it gave me an awareness
of life and that's helped me be the
person I am today so I needed to go
through that Journey Legacy to me like I
said is about helping people realize
their own potential and when I'm dead
because that person's had an interaction
with me or something I've been part of
that's positive their life is better
people don't change
come on look if you're somebody who
actually believes that nonsense then I
really think you're gonna need to
prepare for a major mindset shift
because today's guest returning for his
second appearance on the podcast is just
positive transformation rendered in
human form his name is John McAvoy and
his story of total metamorphosis from
high profile armed robber one of
Britain's most successful career
criminals and Most Wanted men serving a
double life sentence in the high
security wing of belmarsh prison to Nike
sponsor Iron Man athlete prison reform
Advocate and just a living breathing
example of the inherent power we all
possess to course correct the trajectory
of Our Lives no matter how dire the
circumstances it's just one of the most
compelling improbable inspirational and
cinematic Tales you're ever going to be
privileged to hear
our first conversation a little over
four years ago that was RRP 379. uh
remains among the most memorable and
impactful in the 10-year history of the
show so during a recent visit to London
I just couldn't resist the opportunity
to reconvene with John and so this one
which is an old school no video audio
only sorry guys just two men sitting at
a kitchen table Vibe kind of podcast
picks up where we last left off we go
deeper into John's remarkable story it's
also about mindset it's about advocacy
it's about service of course giving back
and again the extraordinary latent
potential we all hold to better
ourselves
as you'll soon discover John's greatest
Heist is not a bank it's his life so
without further Ado please click that
subscribe button and
yeah so mate it's been
[Music]
I looked exactly four years since we
first met
crazy a lot has happened in your life
since the first podcast that we did and
I just kind of want to open this by
saying
um
that uh you know first of all I'm
continued to be inspired by the example
that you set I think it's really an
extraordinary thing and it's been cool
to see you uh you know take the
responsibility that you shoulder
seriously in the way that you give back
and as you might suspect
people often ask me
like what's your favorite podcast
episode like who's the coolest person
that you ever interviewed and that puts
me in a weird position like I don't want
to choose from my babies I've been doing
this for 10 years there's like 700 of
these things
and I often say well it depends on what
you're interested in but I do find
myself
referring new people to your episode or
referencing you in the discussion of
some of the most powerful and impactful
shows that I've done and so that's just
one of many reasons why I'm excited to
pick things up where we first left off
four years ago yeah he's been a journey
since we last uh met each other all
those years ago back in London and um
even the reaction that I've always
received from people that have listened
to a lot of podcasts because I've done a
lot of podcasts since your podcast yeah
for people a lot of people always
reference yours in particular as a as
one that's impacted their lives the most
it's cool man
um in the discussion around kind of what
you've been doing since we since we last
met I mean you don't we're we're right
now we're in an apartment that's like
right in the middle of Portobello road
so if you hear background noise that's
because like there's a lot of Life
happening outside of here but in any
event you don't live here anymore not up
and uprooted yourself yeah I did uproot
myself and if you remember last time
when we did the podcast and I was meant
to do the Iron Man race right I had to
um put out of because the uh my
probation officer messed up all the
paperwork and I wasn't allowed to leave
the United Kingdom unless it was
approved by my probation officer and
they made a mistake with the dates and I
didn't end up racing that Iron Man that
was meant to do in Hamburg
but since then
um the Secretary of State for justice in
the United Kingdom he removed all of my
life sentence conditions and one of
those conditions was I wasn't allowed to
leave the United Kingdom unless it was
approved by my probation officer which
if I'm honest
I never really thought would happen but
it was such it's such a rarity in the UK
that that ever happens to someone
serving a life sentence so when I got
out of prison I'm unlicensed the rest of
my life and when my probation officer
phoned me up she said I've got some good
news and at the beginning when I saw her
number on my phone normally it's bad
news right and I was dreading answering
the call and she said look I've got
something to tell you this this is
really going to impact your life
positively and I asked her okay what is
it and she said what I'm about to tell
you I don't even know what it really
means because we've never done this
before and she said that we've been
contacted by the ministry of justice and
they're gonna take away all your life's
at this conditions which means you can
travel freely wherever yes and I could
live wherever I wanted without prior
approval because before even when I
lived in the UK I had to live within a
10 mile radius in my probation office so
all of that went and then I was allowed
to travel so I was like a kid in the
street shop the first thing I did was
literally go abroad because I didn't
have to ask more
um and it was yeah it was such an
amazing feeling I I didn't realize
subconsciously the effect it had over me
because I kind of always accepted I
couldn't travel so that when people I
knew my friends used to go abroad and I
used to invite me I just used to just
just say no it was just an instant
reaction it wasn't even something I
could contemplate doing because it
wasn't sort of an option to me
um but yeah they removed all the
conditions and I went abroad properly
for the first time in 2019. so just
another example on a long string of
miraculous we've never done this before
kind of incidents right like what do you
make of that like so much of how you've
been able to do what you do is the
result of you know the the sort of
universe conspiring to support you in
ways that you didn't suspect like it's
just you're putting out a certain energy
and at some point you are rewarded for
that I think right like obviously a
decision was made that had never been
made before and your behavior are in
your actions behind the scenes and form
that decision yeah I all the work that I
was doing I never did it for that reason
and I and I do think it is energy and I
think when you put good energy out into
the world and you apply yourself to
positive things I think these things
reflect and they come back to you that
energy comes back to you and and like
with all the work that I was doing um
when I used to have my quarterly
probation meeting like there was a point
where I was having meetings at 10
Downing Street with like at the time she
was prime minister she's made his policy
advising team about opening up school
facilities during the holiday periods
for disadvantaged kids so kids could go
to these School sites and then local
community groups could run like sports
initiatives and give kids healthy food
so then when I'm having my quarterly
meeting operation officer and I'm
telling about this stuff she even said
this is ridiculous like yeah you know
typically she's probably used to people
coming in and telling them about their
bricklayer job or something like that
yeah like are you showing up on time
that kind of thing yeah and and I know I
was doing what I was doing and I and I I
was doing it for the right reasons I
wasn't trying to manipulate people I
just wanted to contribute and give back
and I said this to you in the last
podcast but sport profoundly changed but
the trajectory of my life like without
it I'd have ended up spending my whole
adult life in prison or I would have
died by default so I I believe in myself
I have a duty and a moral obligation to
reach back and help other people and by
that the byproduct of it was that people
in positions of authority and power saw
this and and they gave me another chance
right and they they removed all those
conditions which obviously changed again
the course of my life and where I've
ended up going to to live right so now
you live I'm not sure exactly where you
live but it's somewhere in the Alps yes
yeah and why did you make that choice
and talk a little bit about the
lifestyle there so I was a I was a I was
allowed to start traveling and I entered
the race in a place called abdues which
is very very famous in cycling and they
have a triathlon there and I entered
this race and I went out there and I had
I had an injury I had a foot injury and
I couldn't end up taking part in it and
it would it had been the first time I'd
ever been to the high mountains so I'd
never experienced what the high
mountains was like before
um because when I was traveling I was
going to cities I was going to like
lower parts of France and when I was
going out on the training camp
and
I have never in my life been anywhere
where I felt at home like I've been
obviously for obvious reasons I've spent
10 years locked in a prison cell so I
didn't have control of my environment
where I was getting moved and then when
I got out of prison I was living in
London I was quite nomadic I've never
felt settled and then I went to this
place and then I just fell in love with
it and I I say this quite often the only
thing I've ever loved more than those
mountains is my mum by a country mile
like I've never felt attached to things
like that before in my life like my
stepdad when I was growing up as a kid
he always used to say to me don't have
anything in your life you cannot walk
away from at the drop of a hat and I
kind of I've always been like that I've
never been attached to material products
or
things people like that I couldn't just
go and then I went to this place and I
genuinely fell in love and I've never
felt that emotional connection and I
honestly Rich it profoundly changed me
so either because I'd never experienced
that emotion before to something or a
place
and and I come back because I didn't
live there and then when I was back in
London I was constantly thinking how can
I go back what can I go back for and I
was going back to where I lived in
inter-season so it's when everything
shut and I got a little apartment it was
cheaper because there was no tourist
there and and then I'll come back and I
was going back and I was coming back and
I was doing it as much as I could in a
calendar year and then in 2020 covid hit
and I was in London and June of 2020
I was again going to go out to race this
Triathlon it got canceled because of
covid but I had my apartment Book for a
month and I was in this apartment on my
own for a month and I was going out
hiking in the mountains there was no
racing and I just started looking at my
life and I become quite reflective and I
thought like I have to practice what I
preach I think we get one life
I feel the way I perceive life some
people say it's quite morbid but I think
I probably at best got 40 summons left
in me and I want to be an environment
that I love being in and wake up every
morning and feel a passion for the
environment and place I am in and I
thought I'm gonna I'm gonna practice
what I preach and I literally gave
everything up that I had in London I
gave my I contacted the landlord handed
him my notes on the lease and I thought
I'll make this work I will make this
work and I'll take advantage of the fact
that everything shifted online so I
could work remotely I didn't have to
attend meetings and then I thought and
because people them that I do work with
will get so used to that that even when
things open back up everyone will just
go well John doesn't live here anymore
he lives in the Alps so and I kind of
just carry on doing right what I wanted
to do so you're somewhere in some
Village yeah riding all these epic
climbs that you see in the Tour de
France and living kind of a a really
grounded existence that allows you to
get out and do the things you love every
single day Simplicity yeah simplicity
see like even financially like living
there I probably earn half what I did
when I lived in London but I've I value
the way I want to feel every day and I
want to be a feel content it's not
happiness it's being content it's waking
up in the morning and looking out at the
mountains and feeling content in myself
that I'm I'm at peace and my life's been
quiet sort of turbulent there's been a
lot of noise in my life about it and
again where I am now that's an
understatement yeah
it's been very very turbulent it's been
very turbulent but it's where I am now I
feel at peace and even to the degree
where my whole diet everything changed I
become a vegan living there yeah we're
going to get into that yeah
that's a big shift from the last time
that we spoke but obviously we're here
in London right now there's a reason why
you're here in London you were you were
sharing before we started the podcast
like it's strange for you to come back
and you know process all the over
stimulation but the reason I imagine has
to do with all the advocacy that you do
and and the Outreach and the prison
reform activities and working with kids
and stuff like that and I saw just on
Instagram that you were doing that while
you've been here so yeah talk a little
bit about those organizations and your
involvement yeah so I had a an idea in
2019 on the long run about opening up
school facilities School sites in the
cities to allow children within those
communities to access those schools
during the the school holidays in
Britain which is a six weeks holiday
over the summer a period so to give you
some background children from a lower
social economic environment lose their
cardiovascular system sorry regress 80
percent during the six weeks holiday
because they said a tree they're not
doing any physical activity they're
sitting in front of screens then their
middle class peers they're Educational
Learning regresses by three full
calendar months so when I go back to
school after six weeks holiday the 80
less fitter and they're three months
behind so I knew these stats because of
conferences and stuff I've been to and
to me it was a non-brainer that you've
got these massive facilities in the UK
School sites that the taxpayers paying
for and 70 of all Leisure space in the
UK like football fields a lot behind
School Gates so to me it was a
non-brainer to open up the schools
because most children live within a
two-mile perimeter of the school so you
don't need to get buses they can walk to
school like they would in a normal
school year and we would allow local
community groups to access those schools
and deliver a programming to children so
I went to Nike and I pitched the idea to
them it was just before covid and I
remember it was semi-greenlighted and
enough away it's just going to die and
they completely backed it when kovid
started to shift the needle a little bit
and we started to unlock they pledged a
three-year investment into opening up
these School sites across the UK and um
and and we are where we are now with
open doors and it's my greatest
achievement my great achievement by by
none like anything I've ever done in
sport or life nothing even comes close
to yesterday and the day before going to
schools across the country and seeing
kids that if if they wasn't in that
school and I asked the teacher I said
what would they be doing and who said
they'd be sitting in blocks of flats all
day doing absolutely nothing and they're
running around with their friends
they're cycling for the first time
they're running they were playing blind
football they're just being children and
they're having a childhood and it and
it's making them feel happy and content
and they're being active and they're
with their friends and it's giving them
a safe space with positive role modeling
and I I've got no doubt again if if I
was random little kids and those
teachers Around Me Maybe my life might
have gone down a different road if one
of those coaches or mentors would have
seen me and said you've got a lot of
talent and then they sort of they could
have channeled me into something
positive
and I wanted to spend 10 years in prison
yeah sure I mean there's so many sliding
door sort of scenarios in which your
life could have been very different I
mean you're so smart and intelligent and
articulate you have a facility for
communicating your story and what's
important to you in a really compelling
way and I think that is you know on a
talent level like equal to whatever your
you know athletic achievements are and
you know setting aside mindset and all
of that which we're going to talk about
so that's really cool man like it's
super inspiring what is the name of the
organization it's called open doors so
we we basically open up school size open
doors yeah cool but you're back you're
getting out you're going back to the
house tonight right tomorrow morning
yeah
um because the show is it has been four
years since you've been on and the
show's a lot larger and I'm sure there's
a lot of people listening to this who
have not had the chance to listen to
that first episode or taking the
opportunity to go back I think it would
be worthwhile to recap the you know some
of your backstory worry for context I
don't know how to begin that
conversation because once I tee you up
it just goes forever
monopolize the whole thing but I think
yeah like what is the thumbnail version
of you know how you ended up where you
ended up and how you clawed out so we
have to go all the way back we have to
because it's already started
I got time bro it's cool it's like go
all right go for it you said six hours
right yeah right but I have to go back
before I was born because my biological
father he passed away when my mum was
eight months pregnant with me they've
only been married 12 months he's 38
years old went to bed one night never
woke up had a massive heart attack
so I was born into the world didn't have
a dad really loved as a child like my
mum's got
Six Sisters I had an uncle my sister
like and all these women don't know me
as a little boy I I couldn't have had a
better childhood I was so loved and
looked after I can remember like
Christmases and birthdays my mom used to
like she was a florist but she used to
do everything to make sure me and my
sister had everything we needed and then
we had a happy childhood
and when I started going to primary
school children used to tease me because
I didn't have a dad no my dad never
picked me up but I didn't realize it
wasn't normal not to have a dad because
I just was brought up by all these women
and I've got I sort of go home I asked
my mum what my dad is I'm a young kid
still I'm five six years old my mum
simplifies it says your dad died before
he's born he's gone to heaven but this
this profoundly did something to me as a
child because I had this like
relationship with death from being very
young and I knew I wasn't gonna live
forever now that woke something up
inside me where I didn't want to be
normal and I didn't want to be average
and it made me incredibly ambitious as a
as a young man as a young child and then
as you're growing up you're learning I
loved learning at school was very
inquisitive history was my subject when
I was at school and my mom used to take
me to museums there was the London
Dungeons and HMS Belfast and I used to
watch documentaries on World War II I
was fascinated with all these things and
every month my mum used to get me
magazines at the news agents they were
record Discovery booklets and used to
put puzzles together but different parts
of history and I remember putting these
together as a little kid every month
and in one day it just hit me that that
amberlyn Henry VIII these people would
live thousands of years hundreds of
years before I was even born but I was
reading about them in our flat in
Crystal Palace in South London and they
had achieved something like they they
were remembered after they were dead and
again I was so young I didn't understand
what that was but that's what I wanted
and it was a legacy it was accomplishing
something my life had meaning
and that sort of carried on sort of
festering inside me and then I was
looking around it was like what do I
want to do and and then I became
intoxicated with British Telecom which
they were like the Monopoly in the UK of
like telephone Communications everyone
in the 1980s in the UK had a BT landline
in their house every street corner had a
BT phone box and I can remember being in
my mum's car seeing these BT phone boxes
when we were driving to my aunties and
one day I asked my uncle and I said how
much money does British Telecom make and
I grew up in the area like Margaret
Thatcher so it was all about greed is
good go after it and he said they made
billions and then that seed was planted
and when any adult said to me what are
you gonna do when you get older it was
to own British Telecom and what I'd done
in my mind I equated then Legacy success
to the acquisition of wealth
and then The Perfect Storm was then
created that when I turned eight my
mum's ex-husband that she married when
she was 16 years old come out of prison
after serving 16 years for armed robbery
he was like one of the most prolific
armed robbers in the UK he had five
equivalents at the Old Bailey he was a
multi-millionaire and he's 21 years old
and he come to our home and I didn't
realize he just got out of prison it's
the first time like and a male had come
in that wasn't related to me like an
uncle and I remember he'd come in and I
was just I was mesmerized by him like he
he was very charismatic I remember I
said it in the last podcast black hair
really white teeth big gold watch and
really shiny leather shoes and he went
into the living room and he asked me to
make him a hot drink a cup of tea and I
would have made it and then when he was
leaving our flat he gave me a 20 pound
note it was the first time an adult
would ever give me paper money so I had
coins before like pocket money and and I
was just intoxicated with him and he
pated me on the head and said you're a
good boy and he left
and then when he left obviously the
questions started coming out said to my
mum who is he my mum tried to again
simplify it and said before I was with
your dad when I was really young I was
married to that man and your sister
that's his daughter and then I was I
couldn't you know thanks to my sisters
my sister she's not my half sister
and then that was it and then what you
started doing he wasn't in a
relationship with my mum but he would
come round on the weekends and pick my
sister up and take my sister out and my
mum didn't want me to miss out on
opportunities because my sister was
going to restaurants with him and stuff
and he said Can Jonathan come and Mum
said yeah my mum let me go and there's
the weeks and months progressed he
started taking my sister out less me out
more and I developed this incredible
bond with him like a father-son
relationship like he didn't have a son I
didn't have a dad and we were just
magnetize each other and it was only
when I got to about 10 11 my granddad
passed away
now I knew he was incredibly wealthy and
I I used to sort of pick up on the
conversations he was having with people
around him and I knew when we went out
to restaurants and stuff people treat
him a lot differently to everyone else
like if there was a pack restaurant they
would always find a table for him
um he was in clothes shops spending
thousands and I could see this so again
you get magnetized by the money but when
my granddad died we went to clear my
grandad's flat out my mum and and my
aunt is and my grandad's in in a draw
had an envelope and I opened up the
envelope my granddad kept all these
newspaper clippings and I was from like
all the national newspapers when Billy
got arrested so then suddenly I'm
reading all these headlines about gotcha
and one of the most prolific arm robbers
in in the United Kingdom and and then
I'm sort of then connecting up all the
dots and then I realized this is what
he's about like this
and then 12 years prior to that though
you had no sense that he was procuring
this lifestyle illegally No all he used
to say to me when I was going up that so
he never overtly told me he was involved
in Chrome activity but I could tell by
the way my mum was and the way my mum
used to talk about life and the way he
spoke about life and the way people that
he sort of took me to and I interacted
with like older men like friends of his
they didn't see life through the same
prism as what everyone else that I was
exposed to did like my mum and my mum's
Auntie like sisters but my aunties and
my sister they would see life for a
different lens and there was a very
anti-establishment very like the
system's corrupt and I'd pick up on
these things as a kid the way when
they'd see police drive past calling
pieces of [ __ ] like and and but I didn't
tweak what they were doing I knew they
was all incredibly wealthy but I didn't
know what they were doing and being
involved and sort of in that sort of
circle of people
it had an impact it wasn't the pivotal
moment it did have an impact it was only
when I was 12 and I saw a film made
about my dad's brother Michael who
committed the biggest armed robbery in
the world that was the trigger because I
watched this Hollywood film as a 12 year
old in our flat and Crystal Palace and I
wasn't really aware of my uncle like my
mum shielded me from this as much as she
could but obviously you're indoors
you're watching the TV and this film
comes on channel three and then suddenly
your surname is being spoken about in
this film and then all of these
characters that are in this film my
stepdad Billy is taking me out so like
their names are the people I could
relate to and it was obviously a very
surreal experience and my uncle stole 26
million pounds worth of gold bullion so
that was in 1983 so probably it'd be
worth 100 million now but I didn't see
that my uncle was in prison for 25 years
for that offense I saw Sean Bean a
Hollywood actor sitting on 26 million
pounds with gold bars in Heathrow
Airport and and that was the real
trigger and at that moment and I feel it
does make me feel embarrassed now to say
it but that at that moment inspired me
to become an armed robber because it was
obtainable right and that inspiration
grows out of this like background harm
of the system is corrupt following rules
Is for Suckers or for losers you got to
take what you can take and then you have
this very charismatic Mentor Father
Figure who's showing you how to do it
and slowly these puzzle pieces are
getting assembled to create this psyche
where when you reach a certain age of
maturity you're all in like you're
bought in do you feel like he
was purposefully doing that like I'm
gonna mold this kid into you know a
successor I'm gonna teach him everything
that I know but I have to I have to mold
his mind first so that he can kind of
you know be receptive to this type of
Lifestyle you know what I actually don't
think he did I don't think he deliberate
he didn't he's not like this kid doesn't
have it have a dad I can fill that role
but I am just who I am yeah that's who
he was so you have to understand Rich
the the way that they live their lives
everyone else is abnormal they're normal
so to them it's a way of life it's an
existence like how many times you've
ever watched a film and like you see
someone that's made millions of pounds
out of crime and you think why don't you
just give up why don't you just stop why
is there always that one last thing
right because it becomes it's their ego
so identity it's who they are so
everyone else is abnormal they can't
understand how people function in
society the way that they do they go to
work they pay 40 in tax to a system
that's corrupt so they so that that is
the normal for them now obviously no he
never wanted me to go to prison so as I
get older when I got to 14 started
chewing in heavily from school because
he didn't realize the impact of me being
with him and I was with him more and
more as I got older and I was around all
these organized criminals more more so
the more I'm with them and the more I'm
hearing and you're hearing about people
corrupting the system corrupting juries
like you're hearing about corrupt
counselors that hand out planning
permission and and my steps as you say
to me everyone's got a price you can buy
anyone when anything goes wrong so then
you start looking at the system you hear
about corrupt police officers and this
is all planned in my psyche I go to
school and my English or math teacher is
standing up in front of me and they're
saying well if you don't get a B in
English John you're never going to get a
job and I'm looking at this group of
people over here that multi-millionaire
is at a crime and none of them are
academically clever but they're all very
Street wise so I started just complete I
just completely disregarded my education
it didn't mean anything so 14 years old
I was truing in I did everything I could
not to go to school my mum even got
fined because I didn't go to school and
she used to get really upset but at this
point it she just basically had no
influence over me whatsoever because I
already in my mind made that decision
and then when I got to 16 my mum got
really upset and she sat me down and she
said you need to leave school with some
qualifications you cannot leave nothing
so she got me absent I remember she's
really emotional and I thought you know
what I'm just gonna go I'll set the
exams I didn't do any coursework leading
into them and I turn up in here like
when you're in the Assembly of all the
other pupils and you've got your pencil
and you're sitting on your table away
from everyone so you can't cheat and I I
did it and then left and then a couple
weeks later you get you you get your
grades and I was the last student to
turn up
um to pick my grades up and my head of
year was a man called Mr Vickers and I
really hope he's listening to this and
he did everything he could at that
school not to one exclude me because I
was cheering so much and two he really
wanted the best for me this is something
now I can I can process and I I
understand at the time I just thought it
was a busybody that used to try to get
me in trouble time because he used to
write letters to my mum informing her
that I'd sort of been chewing in 40 of
the year and I come to school I was late
I was disrespectful
and I remember I was the last people to
turn up and he dared like these uh this
box with all the envelopes of all the
students and he and he he pulled out my
envelope he said do you want to look at
your grades and I was completely
disinterested and he said well I'll tell
her and he opened up the envelope and he
I remember pulled a piece of paper out
and he looked at me and he and he said
if only you would have applied yourself
what you could have done and I still
managed to get relatively decent grades
because if I didn't turn up to do any of
the coursework or like none of the
lessons and he said what are you going
to do now and I lied and I said I'm
going to go to college
but the backdrop to this and again it's
only something I've been able to sort of
understand later on because of my uncle
got released from prison at this point
so my surname's in the National Red Top
tabloid newspapers all the time my
teachers quite clearly knew my what my
life was like and they could see the
journey that I was probably going to
travel down and he said to me what are
you definitely going to college I said
yes and he was deeply concerned I
remember even when I left like I said
I'm done with school I'm out I'm
finished I've done it 16 years old they
can't do anything to me anymore he was
still phoning up my mum to check that I
was okay and he was an amazing man he
really really was a great teacher he
just couldn't save me at that point and
he gave me these pieces of paper with
all my qualifications and I walked down
my school drive in beckenham killed near
Kelsey Park he's in South London and I
remember ripping them up and Chuck them
in the Dustbin because they meant
nothing to me whatsoever and I went and
bought a gun that literally when I
bought a gun so that was it I was in I
thought I'm gonna be an armed robber and
my stepdad found out
and this is now the part where I do
think he did think that he was going to
sculpt me because he found out I did
this so I went and bought this gun with
his 40 year old man in South London it
was a shotgun sworn off and he found out
I did this
and he was then so worried that I was
going to be running around with Firearms
he felt that then he would protect me by
bringing me in more
to basically be with him and all the
people he did stuff because he knew he's
going to do this I better guide him
otherwise he's going to get killed yes
but he didn't realize the impact that he
had before this right by being around
him but now at this point now he knows
I'm in and he knows how I am and what I
want he thinks now I'll be protected so
this is sort of where the next part of
the journey ends up beginning where I
started they used to send me out on
tasks so I used to go to security Depots
out in the suburbs where like the
lorries used to fill the Depots up in
the early hours of the morning and they
would like literally and again it sounds
like something out of the film but we
had to go to like Army Surplus shops and
I'd get like net in cocky net and there
was Woods at the back with a camcorder
and I'd film the Vlog he's coming in in
the early hours in the morning at four
in the morning and film it and give
these video cassette tapes to older
criminals and and I had a really good
memory like security vans used to make
deliveries to Banks so I used to follow
the van at the Depot follow it to all
these Banks so then you could calculate
how much money the van had on and I'd
relay all this information across and my
stepdad gets tested when I was 18 years
old
so again the arrogance he gets arrested
I should have known what was probably
going to happen to me but I didn't and I
I I've and I basically feel like [ __ ]
you I'm still going to keep doing it
right and this is my opportunity to now
Step Up
right does that mean like suddenly with
him out of the picture now you have kind
of a green light to you know hit the hit
the gas pedal on this it was already it
all it was already sort of in my mind
because I realized quite quick by doing
what I was doing like I was never going
to become a multi-millionaire like by
helping other people get rich so he he
used to say to me and I said it a moment
ago I referenced it he was a
multi-millionaire and he's 21 years old
at a committing organized crime he used
to sat to me all the time he had a
Rolls-Royce when he was 21
multi-millionaire everyone he was
renowned within the criminal underworld
in the UK as that man that was a
multi-millionaire a young kid and he
always used to bait me with it so when I
was 18 you'd say do you think you're
going to have more money than what I had
when I was your age and he used to bait
me and bait me and make me and then he
gets arrested and then like you said it
was like well I'm just going to keep
going like even though all the alarm
Bells should have rung at this point and
I should have said he's just been caught
the highly probability is the police now
watching me I didn't I just carried on
and the inevitable end up happening and
two months later I end up getting
arrested the conspiracy to commit armed
robbery mm-hmm so that's your first
incarceration and what was the sentence
with that one so I got five years I was
looking at 16 years they made me a
maximum security prisoner so I was I was
not 18 years old when I got arrested and
in the UK if you're under the age of 21
you cannot be kept with adults over 21
but because the Metropolitan Police
believed that I was a higher skate risk
because at this point my stepdad's
double category a prisoner armed police
because my uncle tried to break out of
prison in a helicopter they thought I
had the the means and capability to be
able to escape from custody so they
basically did something called starred
me up which then put me in a Maximum
Security Prison Prison yeah prison as a
as a category a prisoner and there was
only like five young offenders in the
country that were at that level of
security that made me worse I've ended
up going onto this wing with all these
organized criminals like men in their
30s 40s 50s 60s they're all putting this
admiration on to me they're lavishing me
and obviously you're a young kid like
the ego I wasn't scared of the prison
officers because like my stepdad drilled
it into me about showing weakness like
don't let ever ever get broken by the
system so I go into this environment
suddenly all these older criminals and
even the prison officers used to Lavish
respect on you which is crazy now when I
look back
um it sounds like Butch Cassidy and the
Sundance Kid I remember like being in
the segregation unit and uh and I'm I
was looking at 16 years and I got
offered a plea bargain uh two days
before my trial started the Old Bailey
and they gave me five years in prison
and that was the experience where you
were in solitary right and I don't know
what you did but you ended up in
solitary and you did your time in there
and they were going to let you out and
you decided to stay yeah right which is
a really interesting inflection point
that I think reveals the mindset aspect
of this and also the more subtle idea of
how important it is to feel like you
have some agency in your life like that
act of defiance was a way of you holding
on to some level of control in a
scenario in which you had very little
control yeah so I I got um so when I got
moved to another prison they wanted to
strip me naked and take all my clothes
off me and put me in a special suit a
yellow and blue suit so they thought I
was an escape risk because I come from
an adult prison as a Maximum Security
Prison as a prisoner when I got
downgraded and they took me off that
because the sentence didn't justify
because they can't justify it with five
years because it cost so much money to
keep that level security when they then
transferred me to another prison the
government of that prison thought well
if you've just come from there as you
can't create prisoner you were probably
Escape risk of this prison but he
couldn't make me category so what he did
he put me on something called The Escape
list so they want all my clothes I
refused to give them my clothes since
you're not having them obviously you're
in their world they do take your clothes
but they put me in the segregation cell
for seven days for refusing a lawful
order so they got their own rules and
regulations in prison and after the
seven days was up they come to me and
they was going to let me go on the wing
and they said you're going to be a wing
cleaner and it's hard for me sometimes
to really Express this to people because
I I realize how poisonous and toxic this
behavior is I absolutely hated these
people with every ounce of my soul like
I I hated them so profoundly and when
they asked me ordering me to do
something I just did the complete
opposite and I said there's no way I'm
cleaning up your [ __ ] every down that
wing and they said are you refuse
another law folder and I said yes I am
and then they put me back in front of
the governor again that gave me the
first seven days
and then when I went in there yeah he
said to me you must remember one thing
McAvoy he went you're in my what you're
in my world I'm not in yours I tell you
what to do and he smiled at me and he
said I'm going to give you another seven
days confined to sell and then when I
went back to that segregation sale and
it was like a Victorian prison I was in
so it was really old-fashioned one thing
they can't stop you from doing when
you're in there's reading so librarian
used to come around a little trolley and
you better take books off and there was
a book I don't know why I picked it off
the Jolly with Nelson Mandela and I
started reading it and when he was in
prison in Robin Island he used to smoke
cigarettes and he realized one day that
the prison officers was using the
tobacco as a punishment to take away
from him so my head my brain as a 19
year old in this situation I thought
well actually if you think by putting me
in this room as a punishment I take that
away from you and when I come and they
said you're going on the wing said no
I'm not and I sat in that room for 365
days and when I didn't intentionally
realize when I made that decision to do
that I didn't realize it was going to be
for as long as it was but it became like
a bit more of a Mexican standoff like I
didn't want to submit to them and look
like they had broken me but I needed to
feel alive rich like I needed to feel
alive like I was a human and you get put
in that situation and this is where my
journey of exercise began like I was I
was I wasn't good as at sport as a kid I
had no interest in Fitness whatsoever
like I had no Role Models as a kid
whatsoever that was athletic
um in in the UK we have a big sort of
football culture like soccer you have a
football team but I would watch it maybe
go in goal but that was it I wasn't
interested in sport whatsoever but when
I was in that cell
something one day just made me start
doing press-ups and burpees and and I
didn't even know the names of the
exercises when I was doing them at the
beginning
but as I went through this journey every
day I got a routine I used to get up in
the morning and I started exercising and
when they used to come out and do the
checks looking for your cell window I'd
never want it to be laying in bed
because there's prisoners that would
like sleep their prison sentence away
they would just lay in bed all day and
sleep and I used I didn't want them to
see me doing that so I'd be out of bed
at morning at six o'clock I'll be
exercising I'd finish exercising and
then I'd start reading and as the weeks
months progressed I end up building up
and I'll do a thousand of each exercise
therapies press up step up so I used to
get a notepad and pen and I'll do it in
reps of 100 so I do 100 squats 100
press-ups 100 and just go through it and
then start again hundred hundred hundred
right and my whole body just completely
morphed I ended up being sort of a
chubby overweight young man so suddenly
Rich ready I didn't have any body fat to
the degree that when I got released my
mum my mum looked at me and she said she
just looked really sick she said look
what they've done to you and I'd like a
gaunt face I probably lost about three
stone I would say wow
sorry to interrupt the flow we'll be
right back with more awesome but I want
to snag a moment to talk to you about
the importance of nutrition the thing is
most people I know actually already know
how to eat better and aspire to
incorporate more whole plants more
fruits vegetables seeds beans and
legumes into their daily routine sadly
however without the kitchen tools and
support very few end up sticking with it
so because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly and
because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced we
decided to tackle and solve this very
common problem the solution we've
devised I'm proud to say is the plant
power meal planner are affordable
all-in-one digital platform that sets
you up for nutrition Excellence by
providing access to thousands of Highly
customizable super delicious and easy to
prepare plant-based recipes everything
integrates with automatic grocery
delivery and you get access to our
amazing team of nutrition coaches seven
days a week and many other features to
learn more and to sign up visit
meals.richroll.com and right now for a
limited time we're offering ten dollars
off an annual membership when you use
the promo code rrhealth at checkout this
is life-changing stuff people for just a
dollar seventy a week literally the
price of a cup of coffee again that's
meals dot richroll.com promo code
rrhealth for ten dollars off an annual
membership all right let's get back to
the show well this is typically the
point in the story where the epiphany of
self-betterment you know kind of comes
in you're struck with the inspiration to
you know form a new life for yourself
the push-ups the press-ups all of these
sort of things are are changing your
body and you you have this realization
that you could actually change your life
but that is not what happened this was
really still a rudiment entry kind of
Act of rebellion and that that derives
from this anti-authoritarian kind of
streak that was instilled in you in a
very young age it was really a [ __ ] you
to everybody else and a way of feeling
human through exercising that small
amount of control that you had in that
confined space yeah it was it was
Defiance it was a [ __ ] you like when I
used to look for that flap it was like I
was uh I felt like I was a machine like
you you will not break me and I and I
used to process it and then the hate in
me that was the fuel that's what fueled
me to do it it's it's like I look back
now and I think sometimes even now like
if I didn't do that back then I wouldn't
have the life I've got today and I never
intentionally did that then to be where
I am today so I was driven by something
so different to what's in me now but if
that Defiance and that hatred didn't
fuel me back then I wouldn't have the
life I've got today and when they open
up that door and they let me walk right
out to the street genuinely like I was a
hundred times worse than the man they
locked up right so I've got out of
prison now I'm early 20s when you were
doing push-ups you were plotting your
return to be yeah I I used at her bank
robber I had to make I had a mentoring
when I was in prison I would never be
conditioned by them so now and and every
day I used to repeat this is not my life
I have been kidnapped and and what
fueled me was is to think every single
year you've taken of my life I want a
million pounds when I get out that was
the fuel that fueled me during that
whole process and it was it didn't even
enter my mind like to to change like to
me in the world that I grew up in when I
was a younger man like late teenagers
years was anyone that changed this is
what I was brought up to believe was
weak and they'd been broken they changed
they're broken the system had broken
them so when I was in that situation
I wasn't going to be cleaning up their
crap like I they was not gonna break me
no matter what they tried to do to me
they could take everything away from me
and I'd let them have it take it it
doesn't bother me so to me in my mind as
a Young Man Rehabilitation being
rehabilitated was meant that the system
had broken you down and I that I can
remember clearly like being in
situations where I'd be with older
people like men and they would be
talking about someone else that did
change and they would all call them weak
right the system had broken them and I
thought I'm never going to be like that
and my step that I said that always you
say to me the only thing you've got in
this world is your name and if someone
thinks you're a piece of [ __ ] and you're
weak that's it and that stuck with me
during that process and it really really
profoundly stuck with me and then when I
got released as I said I was so much
worse than the person that had
originally been locked up and I remember
going through reception when they would
let me out so I had no visits I had
nothing so I literally got released in
the suit I wore it cool right and it was
all massive because I lost so much
weight and when I was in the reception
area they give you a discharge Grant and
you have to sign the paper and I had
some money in my account where like
family sent me your money and I remember
he said you need to sign this for your
discharge Grant and I was like [ __ ] you
discharge Grant I don't want anything
for a few people and I'll never forget
it as I was walking out he said McAvoy
because they will not call you John he
said you'll be back I said no I won't
and they literally want me to the gate
and they let me out to the street hmm
well a couple things first of all on top
of all of this getting pinched is a rite
of passage right so that's the kind of
context in which you're processing what
had happened to you like this is just
part of the deal like this kind of
happens and you know your community of
people they're not gonna they're not
gonna break ranks with you because this
happened like this happens a lot right
so there's no reason to change course or
change this is just part of the life of
being a bank robber and now I just have
to learn how to be better so it doesn't
happen again yeah it does the complete
opposite right because you've been
tested yeah well the and the testing
part which is where the mental rigor
comes in what's interesting about the
way that you communicate around that or
process it is that it's all about
non-attachment like even earlier on you
were talking about being a nomad like I
I wanted to have this life where I could
just you know have my go bag in any
moment and split like these things don't
mean anything to me like whether I'm
confined to this room or whether or not
I get my you know roll of bills back
when I leave the prison like that's all
stuff that I don't that doesn't Define
me and is not going to drive how I make
decisions most definitely a night like I
said like when I got released I was
blessed but within that world you've
been tested like you've physically
you've been tested by people people now
know you go in there I didn't inform on
anyone people outside in that world knew
how I did my prison sentence that I was
defiant that I fought back so you
basically your stock goes up in that way
right your name is even better you get
more respect and more and people then
people know you can be trusted because
you've been tested it's all wearing good
people saying well you can trust me but
when you are actually in that situation
and people see actually when he was in
there as a young kid and then he and he
acted the way he acted that they can
they can entrust you with their own
Freedom so when I got released that was
another thing it was like you prison
becomes like a bit of a university of
crime and you it's it's an amazing place
to connect up with people like I used to
say sometimes it was so like when I went
back to prison the second time when I
was older but you would get like a a
Colombian drug trafficker and you'd put
him in prison the cell next door was
someone that was in prison for
transporting drugs right she put these
two people together they've all got
their necklace but this is exactly what
is that happening and we and sometimes
you we used to sit there laughing about
it because that's what it's like when
you are in those it's the London Rowing
Club for organized yeah yeah yeah yeah
so how long uh after you get out before
you commit your next crime so I was
released and then I would say within
four days
I found tracking devices on my car so I
was like when I got released I knew they
were very unhappy with the length sense
I got
um and I was I was paranoid and I was
paranoid for the right reasons because
they were genuinely following me around
I found these tracking devices on my car
they had a GPS and a radio transmitter
um I used to have my car put on a ramp
like in a mechanics workshop and my
friends
took my car for the morning and phoned
me up so can you come down we need some
work doing to your car didn't really
turned up at the garage and he took me
to the car under the bay lifted it up
went up to the back bumper pulled off
this block pulled us over block and I'm
like wow like they are on me like I said
in obviously they're not processing
everything who have I seen what I've
been doing because they think when you
get out of prison you're desperate you
need money you're going to be networking
you'll make a mistake and I played a
game with him for a month or so I should
drive around I
um I had like a pretend job my friend
owned a company and what hit me to the
degree how much they run me
I used to have obviously when they were
following me around you have a routine
go gym stuff like that and then one
morning I go to his house really early
because he says come to mind jump in the
work van so my routine's been changed so
even though they're following me around
obviously I've still got a semi-routine
I'm just not mixing with lots of
criminals and put myself in situations
where they could arrest me because I was
I was on license when I first got out
and I went to his house in the early
morning winter dark down Country Roads
parked my car up outside is get into his
car to drive to his office
and then suddenly as we're driving the
way I've just come all these unmarked
police cars little blue lights no Sirens
flying down the road and I thought well
like they are on me like they're
literally 24 hours a day they must have
fought because I'd like gone out too
early in the winter I was actually
saying I was probably going to commit a
robbery and then I the alarm Bell was
really wrong I thought like there they
really want to put me back in there and
I took the tracking devices off my car
and I had a solicitor at this point and
I went up in hat and garden and I
remember I took them off the car I went
in and he was like good God man what are
you doing he went they're probably
listening to us right now so he got his
secretary to take these things outside
and he said what do you want me to do
and I said write a letter to the
Metropolitan Police and say they're
harassing me and he said John I'm
telling you now if we do it they're just
going to come back say we need to
confirm nor deny that we put them there
he went to his pointless
anyway but I'm going to give you one
piece of advice even whatever you're
doing stop doing it even because they
will put you back in prison and I was
like yeah yeah and I thought they don't
know and anyway I then made the decision
Rich my uncle family lived in Spain
um I'd met people that were in the
Netherlands
the minute my license had ended I
literally left the UK straight away and
I remember to sense this relief when I
was on the ferry and I felt that's it
I've won that they're never gonna be
able to put me back in prison again
because in my head now I'm thinking I'm
going to live in Europe I'm just
faceless no one knows who I am the
police don't know who I am and I can
just carry on committing crime in Europe
and I'm just going to blend in I just
vanish off the face of the Earth in
regards to the UK and I did for like 18
months I I was doing all sorts of stuff
I was selling drugs I was down in Spain
and then you get caught into this whole
like young man fast living high octane
being around people with lots of money
living in the south of Spain that
typical lifestyle you'd imagine a young
man in that world would live like living
in the fast lane don't give a [ __ ] about
anything but you'll you feel like you're
on you're meeting all these people that
are all very very rich and I felt like
with my mate I remember we believe we
were on the precipice like we were just
on the edge now of like making it a
night moving up that next level and then
obviously I'll come back to the UK and
um yeah that was where the next chapter
of the story began me going back to
prison right so so walk us through how
you got pitched that second time and
because this is really where the story
truly begins so I was living in Spain I
was living in between Spain and you're
like doing the Ibiza nightclubs fast
boats and big watches kind of thing it
was very similar to that yeah yeah it
just wasn't ibifa it was another very
bad place called Marbella so is that
that life yeah and my friend at the time
was having a birthday party in the UK
and he asked me to come and I felt it's
loyalty to him right I liked him a lot
he done a lot for me in my life and I
thought you know what I'm going to make
the effort and when I was coming back a
girl dropped me off at the airport and
she said why are you going back and I
was like I'm only going to go back for
like a few days six days and I'll be
gone in and out
that was it dropped off at the airport
made decision I wasn't doing anything
illegal with so when I come back I
didn't I hadn't done anything where they
could arrest me so I'm good like I'm all
good I'm living here no one knows who I
am I'm sort of mellowing like I'll
mixing with people and I was committing
crime but I was just not sort of overtly
doing it um to the degree where I was in
the UK and I come back my friend picked
me up at the airport
and I went into a phone shop and I
bought a pay as you go mobile phone I
did not even take the phone out of the
box the phone number was on the side of
the Box my friend that picked me up I
gave him that number because I didn't
want anyone to know I was back in the UK
I didn't want to give anyone my Spanish
phone number because I used to change my
phones all the time just so people
couldn't listen to me or they couldn't
track me and stuff like that so you
should get paid as you goes but because
I was in Newcastle I have an English
phone for six days and I'll just throw
it away afterwards
and he said where do you want to go I
said can you drop me to my mum's he
dropped me to my mom's because I ain't
seen her for a little bit and I was so
tired because I've been out partying and
stuff went around my mum's he goes off
didn't want to go out that night put the
phone on charge next one phone's ringing
so I'm assuming it's my friend that
picked me up because he's the only
person in the world and it wasn't it was
mine and my stepdad's
friends Associates
was on the other end of the phone
I'm like have you got this number and he
sold last night your friend would pick
me up
he went to the pub he was in there said
I just picked John up oh have you got a
number for him he's gave him a number so
he's phoned me out
he said what you up to today and I said
well not really much but I'm going to a
party and he was like oh do you wanna
have breakfast so yeah of course like
when I was growing up as a kid I advised
this man I did like I remember he got
released from prison serving 8 16 or 18
years he got released but by this point
I was in it I was 14 15 years old I knew
what he was doing within that world it's
very well respected tried to break out
of prison two times
um he hijacked a JCB prison um in in
Wandsworth prison trying to Ram the war
and get out he like he he was renowned
within the criminal underworld right no
respect for Law and all that whatsoever
like he was even more extreme than my
stepdad
and he asked me to go meet him and
therefore again the cafe room I met him
was called the chestnut
we were sitting by the window and I
walked in 19 and I embraced him I felt I
just had this connection to him I I
liked him so much as a kid that I
admired him so much
and we sat down and we were just
chatting about stuff and he said to me
do you want to go work meaning do you
want to commit a robbery I was like nah
I'm all right thanks and he was like no
like I said look mate I'm out like I'm
good I'm going back there I don't I'm
not interested then he told me to sign
my money and he said it's easy
and then obviously you're processing it
and I'm thinking you know what like I
could just do it and then go back there
no one's even gonna know and then I
agreed to doing it and and it's just
like every movie well it is it is it's
just sad but I say it's sad I say it sad
it was the best decision I ever made in
my life because I just agreed to commit
in this robbery of him what I didn't
know at that point was outside of that
window was a hundred-man surveillance
operation watching him and I'd been
watching him for months waiting for him
to commit this robbery or commit a
robbery and I just walk into it what
you're listening in on on your meal you
think no they they wasn't listening in
um because obviously when we got
arrested you see all the surveillance
logs so what they did do
when me and him meet I agree to doing it
and I said when when is it he said the
day after tomorrow
I leave he leaves by this point
obviously he's got my number
I go back to my mum's but I was walking
through the park and stuff and I was
thinking well they're not gonna be like
no I didn't even think I was going to be
followed but like I would still go
through the park I wouldn't drive
directly to my mum's or anything like
that
they obviously followed me on foot I saw
that I went back to my mum's address and
they did like a check on my mom's
address so then obviously my name's come
up
the operation just literally blew up
like we saw this in the surveillance
logs literally blew up because now they
know you've got two convicted robbers
together
both high profile
they know he's been looking at things so
he's on right it's an even underground
I've been underground so I just popped
up you just resurfaced so that's like a
gift so as you just walked straight into
this thing and then the next day we went
to do it and then nothing happened we
didn't do it we decided not to but I'm
in now I'm in like I've made in my mind
I've already made the choice to go now
and start doing this so the one we spoke
about didn't happen but I'm in so I'm
thinking well what's the next one so he
goes well there's another one tomorrow
so now I should have just said I'm out
but I didn't and the next morning we go
we had walkie-talkies so we didn't have
mobile phones so they couldn't sell site
us and put us anywhere
and he's in one car I'm in another car
waiting for this fan to turn up to make
a delivery
on the other side of the road the van
comes in I'm gonna walk italki nothing
comes back and I looked in the rearview
mirror and I was parked down like a
cul-de-sac a couple minutes before that
so it was a dead end Road and I looked
and I saw these free cars shoot down
this this to cul-de-sac and my heart
sung I knew it was the place instantly I
knew it was the place the way that the
cars like the suspensions dropped and it
was so aggressive
and I thought oh wow like I'm radaring
him nothing's coming back I drive off
from where I'm parked now I had a friend
at the point at this point that did not
live too far from where we were and I
remember thinking
I'm just gonna get out of this car and
run and jump over garden fences they're
not even going to know I've seen them
and I want to get to my mates and just
get out this country as quick as I can
I'm rich I had this overwhelming sense
of guilt I remember it so clearly I
pulled in on side of the road
and I was radio and nothing was coming
back I kept saying they're on us they're
on us they're on us the police are here
nothing come back and there's so Roman
sense of guilt and I thought I can't
leave him and I did a u-turn in the road
but I didn't see the police had moved
now there are marked police from where
they where that cold is that where they
drove down
and then suddenly I'm driving towards
them and I saw I saw them come in and
then they and obviously they now know
I'm going to see it and add the caps on
bulletproofess and then one of them's
just tore in front of me and like
smashed the front of the car ones come
from behind one's come to the side and
he's kind of stopped me they've jumped
out and I've just seen like this firearm
and I just thought [ __ ] this and I threw
the car into first gear drove up on the
pavement and I kind of got down a little
bit because I thought they were going to
shoot in the car and I ended up getting
away like got on the pavement got around
them and drove off
um and honestly mate like as I'm talking
to you now I had this voice in my head
and I kept saying I'm not going back to
prison I'm not going back to prison I'm
not going back and I may I remember and
and in that brief moment I was fully
prepared to die to try to get away from
him honestly like because I knew what
was coming the first time I went there I
didn't know what prison was like and I
knew that segregation unit I knew the
isolation and I thought I'm not going
back to that place but it was his voice
and my head going I'm not going back I'm
not going back I'm not going back and I
I was driving along and I was trying to
get rid of him because every [ __ ] they
were chasing me and I went down this
back street drove into this like he was
like an old person's home and as I've
gone to get out the car they ran me from
behind the Cars gone up into three
wheels I've smashed my arm in the window
got out and run
and then I've run around like it's like
it was like a rabbit's Warren so anyway
you can explain it
and then I ran into this garage area and
it had all this trellis fencing and I
run in there was nowhere to go and then
suddenly I looked round and you could
see this tsunami of officers running
towards me and it kind of startled them
it startled them because they didn't
expect they didn't expect it suddenly
they've just ran around the corner and
I'm there and and there was an Asian
police officer all like honestly my
peripheral vision I could see them all
running towards me there was one Asian
police officer and I was looking at him
like in his eyes and he was screaming
for me to get down and I froze like I
remember thinking they're going to shoot
me and I and it was like I tensed up
even though I can't deflect a bullet but
you you tense up and I I was like and my
brain's processing what's happening and
I thought he's going to shoot me and
he's going he's screaming get down get
down and I won't get down and then they
just like bundled me to the floor
and then they've all just like basically
doing what they're doing like they were
kicking me and punching me and stuff and
then they they put me in handcuffs and I
remember one of them said stop doing it
there's a window cleaner it's a thank
you to that window cleaner whoever it
was at the time and then they uh they
they lifted me off the ground and then
they put me in the car and straight
around thinking on my feet I'm thinking
how am I going to get out of this and I
thought I'm gonna pretend I've got
concussion because they like sort of
manhandled me so I'm in the car and I'm
shutting my eyes and the cop policeman's
gone you're right and I went I don't
know I don't know where I am and
and I remember someone got in to the
passenger outside the driver's side of
the car and he kept calling my name he
said John John John and I looked up in
the corner of my eye and I recognized
him and it was the police officer DCI
Curry that arrested me when I was a kid
and he and he looked at me and he went
you haven't learned your lesson about
and he's smiling and he went you're
gonna go back for a long time
and then I lit they was all outside all
the police officers and they didn't
arrest the guy I got arrested him at
that point
and I could I was listening and I was
thinking please say you saw them please
say you've not got guns on you because I
thought if there's no guns they can't
prove they've done anything and they and
I could hear the police officers talking
amongst themselves
an egg on it have you arrested him yet I
mean whoever's on his surveillance team
said we've not arrested him he's in a
High Street and then the call went in to
arrest him wherever he was and I was
thinking please say you've seen them
please say you've seen them and the
copper said to the other police officers
he's screaming fit up and we found two
firearms and I just thought oh wow so
how come he didn't respond on the
walkie-talkie I was assuming he already
got pinched yeah they were blocked they
weren't uh it was just a bad area they
just didn't work so there's no
communication there would never have
been communication so then when I
thought yeah I thought they had already
picked him up and what's interesting is
that you weren't really caught in the
act like you were still in the in the
kind of you know lead up to the act so
was the charge conspiracy like what what
would you actually yeah the child the
charge was conspiracy right but the
charge is worse as a conspiracy because
like the Barrister because again this
was all new to me at the time I didn't
really understand it but a conspiracy
the conspiracy goes for as long as
someone engages in a criminal act so say
for instance someone engaged in a
criminal act in 2000 and you joined the
criminal act in 2021 yeah you've got
nothing to do with the 21 years before
that it doesn't matter you're probably
you you get arrested the whole thing so
that when the police were watching him I
kind of got sacked into this whole
conspiracy that I wasn't even part of
like I didn't even know what they were
doing before because you were running
your own conspiracy yeah yeah so I was I
was committing crime yeah and I always
say this about reception responsibility
for your actions and stuff like no one
ever made me do any of this stuff it was
all through poor life choices and when I
got sucked into it at the beginning
obviously you do get quite resentful
because I was looking at all the
evidence and there wasn't really much
evidence on me to a degree
um and obviously you're figuring out how
can I get around this like how can you
beat the system and stuff and obviously
the more evidence that comes you get the
child sheep's going up and up and up and
more and more inflated so when we got
arrested or when I got arrested in the
car
when they transported me to the police
station DCI Curry
um that arrested me the first time I
remember him chatting to me look out the
windows you only went because you won't
be seeing this for a long time and I
remember it was it was a September
morning and there were people like
coming walking around in High Street
with suits like shopping bags and I
thought wow I'd do anything to swap
places with them now because I knew what
was coming and they took me to the
police station
and I was I was in something called
incommunicado I wasn't there to talk to
my lawyer because they were raiding
people's houses trying to find out where
I was living they dug up my mum's Garden
they destroyed a garden like they went
around and ripped her house to pieces
and then um after that period of
incoming a card I was allowed to talk to
my solicitor and he come up and I said
like how bad do you think this is before
I had the first prince police interview
and he said it's bad he meant his bats
considering you've been to prison
already and you're kind I'm still on um
like a license even I was allowed to
travel at this point I was still I'd
still do some of that prison sense from
the time before
and then I didn't realize to the degree
now of what was about to happen but
after I got interviewed I was there for
three days before we went to the
magistrates call I knew I was going to
get reminded but when we was getting
ready to go I thought it was unusual
that the police that arrested me were
taking me to court and then I remember
listening to this big fan it was like a
it was like a big air conditioning unit
so anyone can explain it and all the
radios were cracking and then they took
me out into the yards of the back of the
police station and there was this like
massive like bomb proof prison police
van there was a helicopter flying over
the police station there was armed
police dogs but police officers with
Alsatian dogs all in bulletproof vests
and I said this is a little bit Overkill
and he said we're not taking any chances
of any of your little mates trying to
get you out
and then um do you know what's quite
interesting as well like I know I'm sort
of going off on a to a tangent last year
I put a post up on Instagram and I
remember I remember when I walked out to
the police
um like a compound car partner police
station there was a window and I
remember looking up there was loads of
police officers all staring out like
normal police officers
a woman that was one of those police
officers commented on one of my pictures
and said she she praised me for telling
my life around and she said I remember
you years ago she said like like when
that circus come to that police station
with you there and how young you looked
and she said how arrogant you was
because again it was that Defiance like
really like I showed no fear whatsoever
during it and it was the Defiance of
being strong so that when they took me
out and they put me in that van and I
said what I said and he was like we're
not we're not taking any chances of any
of your little mates breaking you out
obviously I realized how much trouble I
was in and I thought well I'm going to
be in this for the long run but when she
said it to me it really took me back to
how I was and how other people perceived
me
back then right like you still feel like
you're the same person but that ability
of her to reflect back the difference
yeah and now she actually perceived me
at that moment like this young kid
because I did look a lot younger I was
like 21 years old but like you've got
this whole circus around you
like all of this resource put on you to
stop you from breaking out of prism and
you're defiant with them like even then
you don't show any fear it was arrogance
complete disrespect like even when they
was put processing me for the police
station I wouldn't tell him my name my
address my date of birth I would just I
wouldn't comply with them right and was
an interview like it wasn't it wasn't
even like no comment it was literally
just staring off into space and just
sitting there and being completely
defiant with them and then kind of got
took out got in that like that van went
to um the magistrates Court first time I
saw the guy I got arrested with straight
away we're sort of talking he thinks
it's me he thinks the police have been
following me but we didn't know any
evidence at that point
and then we had this slight circus going
from the magistrates Court to the prison
and then I went to belmarsh and then
when I was there again go get in
processed through reception name address
nothing just be as difficult as possible
and they put me in a holding cell and
because I pretended I had concussion
even when I was at the police station
the doctor there to send the doctor to
see me and I was feeling thinking oh if
I pretend I've still got it they're
going to take me to hospital and I'm
just going to try to get out somehow so
when I went to the the
um to prison and they put they were
process for me for reception they put me
in this holding cell they then come to
me and said you're going on Hsu and I
thought it was like a hospital unit or
something they were going to take me to
because I pretend I had a concussion
and I was like yeah and then they really
explained to me what the Hsu was which
is a security unit what is it yeah in
belmarsh which is a prism within a
prison
um and they basically the police made an
application to the ministry of justice
and they believed that my Escape risk
was so high that escape must be made
impossible so they put me in this unit
that was built in like the late 1990s to
house the IRA
um and it was basically we used to quote
in the Batcave it was like a it was like
he was underground you wasn't but like
there was no natural light it was like
those Banks of like lights you get in
hospitals that fluorescent light stuff
always humming I always remember the
little hams they made
and they um they put me in a little van
they drove me through the prison
handcuffed up and then they took me on
this unit and like none of the doors
have got keys they're all it's all
intercom so you can't take hostages and
then they yeah they put me on that this
tiny little unit and I thought I'm in a
lot of trouble here like I'm I'm like I
really and this was even before a
sentencing this was like on romant right
it was on remind and the prison officer
said to me like you've got you've
basically had a choice when I got on the
unit there was it was so small it was
like it's very hard to explain unless
you've seen it with your own eyes it's
like a little submarine it's any way you
can explain it and the prison officer
said to me look John like they call you
first name on there there's a lot more
respect on there it's more adult I found
in regards of how they treat you and he
said look you've been in the police
station three days he went you're you're
like spur is on exercise if I was you
I'll take your exercise you won't get it
until tomorrow so I said all right and
then he said look put the little kit I
did that I've been to myself you get a
bar of soap and stuff and then they they
walk me downstairs free prison officers
and all these in the Comm doors airlocks
Manchester one opens and then they walk
you outside but you get this feeling
that you're still inside but you're
outside like there's so much
anti-hellicopter why it's like a hamster
cage right so we were walking for this
little tunnel and I looked up and like
you can see the sky but it's so meshed
up that you feel like you're still
inside but you're not and then we got to
this like quite a big exercise yard
because you know how small the
environment was at the unit and then
they press a button and there's a prison
officer in a little cage box thing
because he can't go on the exercise yard
with anyone so no one can take him
hostage and he lets you on the yard and
then I walked into this quite big yard
considering there was only like six
seven or seven other prisoners walking
around in a circle
and then really the the reality of the
situation really dawned on me when I
went out there and shag Abu Hamza was
fighting extradition to America for
terrorism and then you had the 21-7
suicide bombers that were on trial
trying to blow up the truth Network in
London and I thought I am I am [ __ ]
like yeah I mean you know people aren't
the world's most wanted list basically
yeah like it was but again it was a very
similar experience because before I bear
in mind I was outside so even when I was
in Spain like it was everywhere like the
news you would see these attempted
suicides yeah global news but then
suddenly you're then in a situation
where two weeks before you're reading
these stories watching Sky News or
something and you're seeing these people
and then suddenly you're there with them
and it was it obviously at one point
it's very surreal
um and even that rich like when when I
went there like Hamza he uh he come up
to me he said like brother do you need
anything do you want some wheat a bit do
you need food milk and all that stuff
and I was like no I'm absolutely fine
and and the guys that were in there
trying to blap the tube I mean I want to
speak to them I'd never spoke to them
for three months when I was in there you
can imagine how awkward it is like I
mean how many people total are in this
unit so there was me there was one guy
in there he was a contract killer he'd
just been convicted and got life of a
minimum of 35 years then Sheikh Abu
Hamza and the four guys tried to blow up
the tube Network in London and I used to
speak to the guy that was in there for
the contract getting just being
convicted I mean he was waiting to get
moved they called it being shipped out
to another prison but we're all Maximum
Security high-risk prisoners I was level
two so that meant when I got moved out
of prison I'd have to be given an armed
escort and a helicopter
um I would so I wasn't a threat to
National Security the guys are never
terrorism they referred to National
Security so their level of security was
mine but we were on it for different
reasons so with me it was because they
believed that the money means and
capability to be able to escape from
lawful custody with them because they
reflect National Security is like if
they do Escape they're gonna kill people
right so then it'll be an international
Scandal yes even though they might not
have the capability to do it it's the
even the remote risk that they could do
it so we were all in there together but
we were in there for different kind of
reasons and I just remember one day
being on this because when we had
Association for the hour a day we had to
come out ourselves we weren't allowed to
sit in ourselves so the cameras could
see us and I remember
um Ramsey Muhammad was talking to Omar
and they were talking about Arsenal
football
I remember listening like
you think they're talking about things
that you're familiar with and then
something I don't know in my head I
thought I'm never gonna be in a
situation like this ever again in my
life where I'm going to be exposed to
these sorts of people and again being a
kid I was very inquisitive and then I
thought I'm going to start talking to
him and I did and I started speaking to
them and I wanted to understand the
psychology behind what they did and why
they did it and we would have
conversations about politics and about
life and I found I found the process
very sort of fascinating right what did
you learn
that they weren't too dissimilar for me
as a kid
um hated the system chose to attack it
in a different way to what I did
um I went down the road of organized
crime and money most of them didn't have
dads as kids they become radicalized
when they got a little bit older went to
like a Moscow where they were where
where it was like a radical preacher
like Abu Hamza and that indoctrination
of them I could never understand why
they denied what they did that was that
was a thing we used to speak about quite
a lot like I've been in prison with
people that were in there for other
forms of terrorism the IRA and the way
they perceived what they did it was a
war and then when they got caught they
wouldn't admit they wouldn't deny what
they did they would just waste millions
of pounds of taxpayers money to go on
trial they would deny what they did well
not all of them not all of them but that
group did so I found interesting that we
used to have a conversation about they
said they were innocent that was their
argument they said we haven't done it
and I said right if you haven't done it
you haven't done it it's not for me to
judge you I'm not your juror or judge if
you say you haven't done it it's your
trial and and then they they went on
trial and they they all got found guilty
and they got I think they got life some
of them got a whole life tariffs but the
common theme being a broken system that
let them down people who fell through
the cracks and in you know kind of a
point in time in their lives where they
were very impressionable found
themselves you know under the influence
of a very charismatic person who could
mold and radicalize them yeah which you
know yeah there's a lot of similarities
between your story and that was
something I identified when when I when
I used when I used to talk to them like
I strongly disagree with what they've
done and then what they went on to do
but talking to them on a human level
again they never admitted their guilt
but when you listen to their stories and
you listen to how they've got to the
position or point of thinking how
they've reached that point you
understand how those decisions got made
in the way that they did probably if
they would have my step that is a role
model as a kid they would have probably
end up going down the road that I end up
going down do you feel like They seized
an opportunity to try to radicalize you
I mean didn't didn't Shake Abu Hamza
give you a Quran he did he did it was
the biggest book I've ever seen in my
life I went and had a shout no I didn't
well I did so when I come back in off
exercise I went and had a shower because
we had like a tiny little moment of
Association and obviously I've been in
the police station for those days and I
went and shower and when I come out my
the shower and I went to my cell there
was a Quran on the on the bed the
biggest book I've ever seen like genuine
it was massive and he put some Weetabix
and milk and I took the book and I went
back to him I said I'm fine thank you
and he was fine he said yeah okay I
thought it might be something nice for
you to read I said no absolutely fine
don't believe in God so he he took it
back and then he didn't Vibe you no no
no no do you know what it was very
interesting like being with him in
regards of like obviously the way the
media portrayed him that was what I was
seeing on the outside but then when I
was with him he was probably one of the
quietest people I've ever met well
obviously everything I ever saw in the
media was outside doing sermons and he
was very aggressive but when I was with
him he was very Placid very quiet
um yeah it was just interesting seeing
the two characters of him yeah he he
ended up getting extradited to the US I
don't know what's going on with him he's
in a super max unit in Colorado does he
yeah and what what again
he didn't he get Gravely ill or there
was some kind of metal he had
um again this is again being inquisitive
like obviously it's glaring obviously
he's got no arms and he's got one eye
right so you would assume that I did I
said did you bow your hands off building
a bomb and he said he was just sort of
getting rid of landmines in Afghanistan
I think it was and that's where he said
that he basically he lost his arms on an
eyesight but we was having this
conversation about heaven and hell I I
don't believe in God I used to as a kid
I grew up in a Catholic Family but I
don't believe in God at all um I think
once we die we die that's the end of it
I wasn't alive in World War II I know it
happened because I know people are alive
when it happened so I know it was a
thing but where was I I didn't exist so
I think the same thing happens when I
die to be like going into a long sleep
and never wake up and this is how you
believe now yes yeah even
even upon reflecting upon your insane
Arc and everything that's occurred like
you can't find some strain of of
spirituality and that notion that like
you you endured all of these things that
you endured to be able to do what you do
today and you know in that like I'm able
to see some kind of non-denominational
Divinity like there seems to be a
greater purpose beyond our perceptive
abilities to calculate that is operating
here like
otherwise it's too insane
but where do you think all the animals
go that die
because I don't know I don't I don't
purport to have an answer to that only
to say that I do believe that there's
more going on than maybe our small minds
are able to truly comprehend and maybe
I'm wrong but maybe at the end I might
have to have that conversation with
someone at the end at the end of my life
but the way I see life is that like I'm
in a I'm at the moment I'm in a very
content
happy place I I and I've I've got to see
how beautiful the world is I don't
really want for anything to a degree
like I live a nice simple life and I'm
happy like that but I think everyone has
the right to live how I live so I think
that whilst I am a breathing and I am
alive and I am on this Earth I should
help other people have the same standard
of existence as me and they shouldn't
have to go through [ __ ] and and not be
able to live their foolish life whilst
they've got it but I do think when the
lights go out the lights go out and I
think that's the end of that and
Christmas my mum's partner that she'd
been with for like 30 years he was dying
of cancer and it's spread all around his
body and he was in palliative care and
he was at my mum's and he was in he was
in the living room and then like then
they bought the NHS bought a bed round
because stop him from getting sores and
stuff and he and deteriorated massively
like he was on a concoction of drugs and
he didn't know he was dying which again
it was crazy like my mum knew it spread
through his lungs to his brain and he
was dying and I remember my mum promised
him she said
like I'll always be here or Jonathan
will always be here and my mum would not
leave his side unless I went around her
every morning and stayed next to him
whilst my mum would go to the park or
the shops and honestly rich I did think
at one point I wonder when we're sitting
there like me and sharing experience
because sometimes it was just me and him
and I was watching him struggling to
breathe like maybe I might think
there has to be something else and I
didn't but what he did when he died it
really sharpened up to me how short and
fragile and precious life is and for me
to live the life that I feel is the
right life for me to to for me to lead
because we've gotten we're all on the
top like on the timer and it and that's
going to happen to me one day if I even
get to 72 or 73 years old like people's
lives are so fragile and so short and
and it and I took the positive that
seeing what I saw
um obviously I didn't want him to die
but when I when I watched him die it was
like it really heightened in me how
fragile my life is and what what a
precious gift life is and being able to
physically able to use my body to sort
of experience the world he experience
the mountains because one day I won't be
able to do it so whilst I am able to do
it I want to really maximize that time
and and have as many life experiences I
possibly can whilst I'm still alive
I feel like my sense is that that
experience affirmed the sense that you
had when your father passed away like
this notion of finality like when your
dad died is that when the idea of Legacy
becomes super important like it it falls
on the heels of that right like and
Legacy is related to the finality of
death right so in your subconscious mind
when you're dead that's it there's
nothing more I need to do everything I
can while I'm here in this finite period
of time to ensure that you know my name
lives on or that I'm doing doing the
works to make the world a better place
like that seems to rent a lot of space
in your head yeah massive death is
profoundly shaped my existence like
going back to being in prison like when
the Catalyst for me changing was the
death of my friend without my friend
Aaron dying there's no change right
we're only halfway through the story
yeah yeah I told you to give me the
thumbnail but like yeah we haven't even
gotten that part but yeah no go ahead
yeah but when when I found out my friend
died like I'm not an emotional person I
never I never have been like
I could probably count on one hand the
amount of times I've cried since I was
20 years old but when I was a kid maybe
a lot but when I'm an adult handful of
times and the night when I found out my
friend died was the most emotional I've
ever been as an adult like genuinely I
couldn't stop crying because the the
relationship I had with him in this Bond
died with him and then I realized I'm
never going to see him again and that
that profoundly changed my existence
because
I was then reflective on where I was
what I was doing I'm in prison
like I thought I was at War this
imaginary war against his system the
things I placed importance on money
wealth wasn't important the people I
idolized as a kid were all Old Men
rotten in prison or they were dead but
him dying awoken me to the nonsense of
the stuff that I thought was important
in life and it wasn't but obviously I
was trapped in an environment where like
I couldn't just get up and walk away and
go I want to turn my life around the
change I want to stop taking drugs I
want to stop drinking I'm just going to
go and do something else I was
physically trapped in this environment
around which is a very negative
environment to be trapped in and I I've
said this countless times but it is like
being a drug addict trying to get off
drugs but being locked in a crack then
trying to get off drugs so I'm in prison
trying to I wanting to not to be around
these sort of negative toxic people but
I'm trapped with them I can't just get
up and walk away and I and I what really
hit me was the following morning after
my friend died we was in a communal
eating area and then there was Prisoners
next to me and no one obviously knew
what what had happened that night and
the fact that I'd been told that my best
friend had died in a car crash
committing a robbery in the Netherlands
but I just remember them talking about
when they get out of prison they're
going to do this that that they want to
stab this person did this person's done
this and I just thought you know what I
can't be around these people anymore I
just do not want to even be near these
people and I was lost like I genuinely
was lost I didn't know what I could do
to get me out of this horrible toxic
environment I I was going through this
process of wanting something else but I
didn't know what that was I've still
driven still focused but my whole
identity is wrapped up in this crime
world like my ego people respecting me
my name that my percept as you say was
so important your name if you don't have
a name you're a piece of [ __ ]
everything's wrapped up in this this
world and I'm in this prison and I'm
like I don't want this anymore I want to
let go of it I don't want to be living
this existence
I was so lucky that I went down the
prison gym and there was a prisoner on
an indoor round machine called Mickey
still from North London in Tottenham and
he was he had gym every day and I never
because in prison you don't get gym
every day because they they try to keep
all the wings apart from each other
because the gang activity but he was on
that round machine every time I went to
the gym and he wasn't on my wing and I
said to him what are you doing and he
said I'm running a million meters for a
charity so I I have a special note they
allow me to come down the wing and and
sort of come down to the gym and row 5K
a day 10K a day five car a day two car a
day and he was just chipping it off so
he rode a million meters he said you
should do it and he put that little seed
in my head and I thought you know what
I've never been on a Rams stream my life
I'm 26 years old and I went to ask the
gym manager called Craig and I remember
it had bald heads and I went in there
and I said to Craig can I do what
Mickey's doing he said John Young Wing
you get sponsorship you can come down
here you can do it so I did it right
we should say that when you when we were
talking about the story earlier you
hadn't even been sentenced yet so
ultimately you end up with a a double
life sentence yes right so two life
terms I don't know how the British
system differs from the United States so
I'd be interested in hearing how you
even got out to begin with because that
doesn't seem like a predicament that
anybody comes out of no matter how good
your behavior is but ultimately you find
this you know opportunity to get into
the gym with you know quite a bit of
bandwidth to use this rowing machine and
this is really the inflection point for
everything that follows yes so is it
going back to the sentences I was in
that unit for two and a half years went
into control I realized that the the
cards were completely stacked against me
my my legal team said
you've you've got to make a decision you
either fight it and if you fight it and
you get found guilty you're probably not
going to get a prison to you in your
mid-30s I was okay I'm 22 years old
and you have to then start assessing all
this stuff from night 35 being 22 feels
a long way away and then they then come
back to me my my legal team I was on the
wing and the prison officer yes I was
the senior officer come to myself and
said Mr McAvoy
um you need to phone up this is uh it's
important
just okay got on the phone
rang him up and he said John I'm going
to ask you something
I know what you're going to say to me
but I have to ask you it I'm legally
bound to ask you I said okay
I said the police have contacted us and
if you give evidence against your
co-defendant
you'll get a substantial reduction in
your sentence
and then I said you know what I'm going
to say to you don't you and he said yeah
and I said but can you pass this message
on to them he said yep
I say go tell them to [ __ ] themselves
and he said Okay And he laughed he said
I'll tell him what you've said and he
went back told him that so I could have
had a massively reduced sense I probably
wouldn't have got life
and then we go to court
um I ended up going get away because I I
really didn't have any I had to wear all
the scenarios I mean his high security
unit I'm surrounded by terrorists
looking at not getting out of prison
time in my MidFirst is
um all my 20s are going to be gone no
matter what I knew that I knew like I
was 22 going on 23 at this point needed
yeah 23. so I knew all my 20s was going
to go I knew that so I had to start
assessing that it was damage limitation
now and then went to court to get
sentenced
and before we went to get sentenced the
prosecution stood up and said my own art
there was something like a public
Community interest request
so I didn't know what that even meant
they cleared a whole Court out we go
back down to the sales our maximum
security so we're in a special little
sort of part of the sales under the
courthouse where no one can come near us
the only people that can interact with
us are prison officers that I bought us
from prison my legal team rushed
straight down and said what is this and
they said basically the whole courtroom
gets cleared out the prosecution the
police and the judge are left in that
room right and I said what does that
mean and he was like ongoing
investigations that they don't want you
to be aware of
um because it might be like they're
putting other people on surveillance
things they think you've been involved
with
so then obviously I know what's coming
we go back up to the court after about
an hour or so of recess and I'll stand
in front of the judge he calls me up
first to stand up all the police are in
the gallery my mum's in the public
Gallery prosecution everyone that was
involved in the case from serious and
organized crime agency robbery Squad and
the judge asked me to stand up and he
starts talking and and then suddenly
when he starts getting to the nuts and
bolts of what he's doing when he's
summing up he started saying about my
age the level of offending my links to
criminal underworld
I thought he's coming
and he said Mr McAvoy I believe you will
always pose a risk to the public the
likelihood of being rehabilitated it's
very remote
and if you do get released from prison
the likelihood of you reoffending to the
higher end of the statutory book is very
high even and I believe the public will
always need protection from you he said
I'm giving you a life sentence
and he said I'm also giving you a
license for possession of firearms
and I'm like okay and then you then wait
for the Tariff so
people that don't understand how life
sentences work
a life sentence is a hundred years or 99
years
now if you commit murder in the UK with
a firearm the minimum starting point of
a life sentence is 30 years that means
you have to serve a minimum of 30 years
in prison before you can be considered
for parole some people get whole life
terms it's very rare that people in the
UK get whole life terms there's only
about 40 prisoners so when he gave me my
life sentence what that technically
means is you sign your life over to the
state so when you get released from
prison on that tariff whatever resets it
out
you can't travel you can't live where
you want they don't have to prove you've
been involved in crime they just have to
suspect you've been involved in crime so
that would mean if I was under a
surveillance operation and I was seen
with a criminal that was a drug
trafficker and the police were watching
that person saw me with him that person
gets arrested for drug trafficking and
they go to my vibration office and goes
John McAvoy has been involved or hanging
around with organized criminals I'm
recalled back to prison that's it I'll
go straight back to prison they don't
have to prove I've been involved in
anything so the judge gave me one life
sentence then he gave me another life
sentence and then when he gave me both
of our senses he set the Tariff of a
minimum of five years because he said if
I were to give you a fixed term I would
give you 10 years but the five-year
tariff doesn't really make any
difference no one gets out in their
tariff and I knew that when he gave it
to me so he gave me these life sentences
and I sat back down and then my
co-defense stood up he was older than me
he had more previous convictions so he
got life with a minimum Tariff of 10
years
so we go downstairs and I remember the
prison officers like like how are you
and stuff I said I'm actually fine but
because in my head I was like there's no
way you're getting these licenses out of
me like the minute I get an opportunity
to run for that gate I'm gone
um there's no way I'll get released from
prison and then spend my life living in
the UK and like be recalled back to
prison every five minutes because these
are the stories that you get fed by
other prisoners and people have
experienced system
so I'll go back to the um back to the
unit they take us back there and then
someone comes and it's easier to make
sure you're not suicidal because you've
just when I sit down I'm fine I'm all
good I'm all good and again it was
putting that bravado on um but again you
do sit there because
you've got a release date like you've
got a tariff but no one gets out in a
tariff so now I'm in this this this
distorted like you're in this sort of
world
where you haven't got any control of
your existence to a degree like your
environment should I say and you've got
no actual date of when you're ever going
to get out of this place so a lot of
people psychologically really struggle
because like when's is ever going to end
because you've haven't got like before I
had a release date I knew on that day I
was out that was it nine o'clock in the
morning you're walking me to reception
you let me back out into the street this
situations the whole game has changed
because I know technically they could
keep me in there if they don't think
I've been rehabilitated I'm not getting
out of prison they will keep me in there
for the rest of my life because they can
they don't have to let you out so I go
back to the unit
they then transfer me to a Maximum
Security Prison up north in the UK and
obviously Rich you're processing your
environment right
what cards have I got to play it and I
didn't have many I wasn't gonna have to
escape they made that impossible like I
had access to mobile phones when I was
in prison and I was talking to friends
outside on a mobile phone and they were
saying we get you if you there's an
opportunity we come and get you and I
said they've boxed everything off
there's no way I'm getting out doing
that there's no chance so that was off
the table so then the other way the
other the other way you would play the
game is that you can fight them every
day like I did the first time and never
get out of prison and I didn't want that
to be my existence on Earth so the Third
Way was you play the game good behavior
yeah you play the game so I knew if I
did what they wanted me to do and did X
Y and Z when I go on my sentence plan
boards every year so you sit there in
front of like probation the the senior
officer the principal officer on the
wing everyone basically writes your
sentence plan out for that year and they
say this year we want you to do like
enhanced thinking skills victim
awareness we want you to get a B in
English we want you to do a B Tech we
want you to do whatever is and you do
all that it's a tick the Box exercise
and you go back up the following year
and in the following year and it was
working after year one I dropped from
being a double category a prisoner to a
category a prisoner and then they made
me took me to a category then they
dropped me to category Bay which is
their security so now they can't justify
holding me in a Maximum Security Prison
anymore so I get my I get a legal lawyer
like a prison specialist that
specializes in prison law bombarding
them illegal letters Mr McAvoy should
not be catching your establishment he's
done everything you've asked him to do
he's now like four three and a half four
years into his tariff he's only got a
five year tap you need to progress in
for the system and they did well they
have to because if they don't Advance
you in that way then it becomes a
referendum on the legitimacy of these
policies that they claim are you know
the the path to Rehabilitation so if
you're not rehabilitated and you've done
all of that stuff it means their system
doesn't work exactly but you know that
which it doesn't but everyone knows that
you're in this you're in this crazy
environment like what I can remember
like when you would do like there's a
there's a course called it um enhanced
thinking skills so like I've gotten the
course for four or five weeks right and
then you get your prison like you just
the guy next door on the cell next door
he has to go on the course after you
right the next enhancement is good so he
goes what do they give you so you give
him all of your stuff right and then
what he does he copies it all out
basically and changes the index offense
to something else but it was absurd what
are the things people are gonna do but
this is this is it and when you're in
there you're in this sometimes you're in
this situation like we was on a victim
awareness course and I remember it was
in the chaplaincy the the chaplain was
called Gareth and again I hope he's
listening to this because he actually
messaged me on Instagram it was really
lovely what he said because he
remembered me and we was all sitting in
this church in prison or the chaplaincy
he was running it they bought this old
lady to come in and I remember it
Christmas
someone back with a house stole all of
her husband's eye insulin right their
Christmas was destroyed they stole all
the Christmas presents under the tree
you've got a group of inmates all of us
have been involved in organized crime
you had drug traffickers armed robbers
people in there for like multi-million
pound fraud tax evasion stuff in this
maximum prison so we're all saying what
a piece of [ __ ] the person was that
stole that put like the old lady's stuff
because that's not what we did like we
didn't do stuff like that so we're all
sitting there and like you're you're
thinking well if you would ever caught
the burglar did that to that little old
lady and you're in this like mad crazy
world where you've got your own moral
Campus of what's right and wrong that's
terrible like that's the worst the worst
that's like scumbags do stuff like that
and you'll you'll engage is such a
bizarre situation that you're in but you
know if you do all these you do all
these tick the Box exercises you do
everything they want you to do they have
to let you progress because if they
don't like what you've just said they're
then acknowledging the whole thing is
farcical and like there's no point to it
so they have to you progress and
obviously when you're in there you know
that so you all the people that do some
people don't the first time I didn't I
didn't engage with it whatsoever and
there's a lot of people that won't like
they will Point Blank refuse to do
anything that they're asked to do in
regards to that stuff but because
they've got a determinate sentence
so they're going to get released they
don't need to do it they don't they're
going to get released no matter what
don't get me wrong Rich there are some
people that it might work for but the
vast majority that I come across in the
in the situation I was in in that
Maximum Security Prison it was it was a
complete waste of money it was a
complete waste of money so how long were
you in before your friend passed away
like if that was you saw that on the
news or something like that right so I
spoke to my cousin on the phone
um and he was the one that informed me I
was watching the game of football
Natalie in prison and Republic of
Ireland playing France and at half time
I couldn't believe that France was still
in the game because I thought France
would I'm sorry Ireland was still in the
game I thought France were going to walk
all over them and they didn't and I
spoke I sprung my cousin up half time
and said are you watching this game and
he said are you on your own and I said
yeah of course I am
and he um and then he told me about um
Aaron dying in the car crash and I was
in disbelief how long had you been
incarcerated though at that point four
years what have you been in four years
four years so during that four years
you're checking the boxes but you're
still harboring this mentality of
defiance your friend passes away this
lands on you like a ton of bricks and
that's really you know the beginning of
you you know rethinking your whole
approach to life yeah but like I said it
profoundly it profoundly changed me and
how what I thought was important and
what wasn't important and obviously I
won't repeat myself but that story with
the prisoners talking about what they
were gonna do when they got out and
me going down that gym and seeing Mickey
and then me looking at what he was doing
and seeing that form of escapism on that
row machine like that there was a portal
outside that wall
and I got on it and it got green lighted
for me to do it and I got the note and I
was able to go down the gym every day
the first session I did was 20 miles
didn't know what I was doing never been
on a rowing machine but you you had been
doing like these CrossFit competitions
and stuff I've been doing so you were
fit I was fit and and again like when I
went back to prison the second time the
exercise the feeling alive someone said
that when you're in prison you don't
live you just exist so when I went back
the second time that started again like
when I was in that cell it was it was
the circuits it was the exercise it was
a train it made me feel like I was a
human being so I I had awoken an ability
in my body I knew I was very fit for
being in prison but when you're in
prison you're in a bubble it's not
reality like you're not in the real
world so I had nothing to test myself
against but suddenly you go on this this
machine and you can actually I wish I
didn't know at the point at that point
but you you can test yourself against
other people like because there's people
that do specific distances over a
certain time like over a certain time
and how quick you are and this all
become new to me like I had this
awareness of it when the prison officer
bought in all these pieces of paper and
he showed me all these records but the
first time time I got on it like and I
suppose to a degree what you've said
about the spiritual component like to me
exercise then made me feel alive it
wasn't about performance it wasn't
performance driven whatsoever it made me
feel really alive like I was a human
being and when I got in that round
machine for the first time
I remember it transcended me out of that
place like genuinely I didn't know
really understand about endorphins and
feeling like in Flow State these words I
didn't know if I didn't know I never
heard them before but when I look back
now reflectively in that process like
being visualization on that Ram machine
imagining I was running on an ocean and
it was like a portal out of that prison
it took me out it removed me and took me
out that place so the first month
I thought this is amazing and I rode a
million meters in a month like Mickey he
was into four months doing the first and
then the next month I asked to do it
again and in three months I'd rode three
millimeters and it was only one day a
prisoner went to me you do realize if
you rode five millimeters it's
equivalent to run across the Atlantic
and I and I didn't I didn't know that
and then I thought that's quite a cool
thing so I've done row fiber near me as
road across the Atlantic it's got an
indoor air machine so I asked if I could
continue and the prison officer Craig
said John keep raising money keep doing
it keep coming down him every day at
this point I had a gym orderly job as
well they gave me a job because I was
down there so much and like Rich my
hands were like claws like literally
because I was holding the handle for so
many hours a day I just have to like
Snap My Fingers out and I'm genuinely
like they were like it was like They
seized up needed oil in the joints and
my body completely transformed more than
even doing the circuits I lats my
shoulders blew up like my body went
through this process like I morphed to
the machine basically and
again one day
you quit luck Destiny Darren Davis the
prison officer Walks Behind me and I
rode 10 000 meters and I pre-program
pre-programmed it in because normally I
used to just roll a distance so the
clock would go up but this day I'll put
10 000 meters in to program it so it
wrote down and then when I stopped on
the 10K Darren walked behind me the
prison officer
and he just stopped and he looked at the
Monitor and he went that is really
really really fast
and I didn't really think anything of it
and then he was the one that went away
and printed all those world and British
records on the indoor Ram machine
and he come back to me in the gym and he
gave him to me and I and I remember like
reading them
and I'm sorry they can't be real because
like I could nearly break some of them
at that point I knew I could and he
planted the seed in my head and he he
went away in like I went back to myself
and I was like I wonder if it's even
possible to try to even do him here and
I asked him he said let me look into it
and he he contacted the people to
officiate the records he explained the
situation because normally you'd have to
do it in a public setting you'd have to
be independent verifying Witnesses I
needed to be weighed because I was doing
it as a lightweight man and a 75 kilo
um I needed to put a card in the round
machine said pull the data off to make
sure no one cheated someone had to take
pictures of me on a scale to make sure
that I was 70 so I was at 72 kilo at
that point
but the biggest point was and the
hardest point of all this was the
governor of the prison and uh Gareth
Sands his name was very religious
Christian man Darren went to him and
Darren asked him
if I could attempt to do his records
bear in mind this had never been done
ever like this doesn't exist right in
prison this does not exist yeah no one's
ever even asked there's never been a
prisoner in the UK prison system or in a
world that I'm aware of that's done
something like what it's amazing they
even had an ERG well that's it it was it
was even like obviously as I as I
Started Loving rummy more and more more
I started used to take care of the
machine as best as I could I used to
wipe all the slides it was shiny so
there's no friction and stuff and Darren
went to him and and they was always
neglected the cardio Suite in the prison
was always neglect everyone's in the
weights room so I always had the round
machine and stuff so it was mine
basically I used to look after it and
stuff as best as I could and Darren went
to him downstairs I think this could
change John's life and the government
said yeah if you think it can change his
life he can do it and the first record I
broke I attempted to break and broke was
the marathon and I broke it by seven
minutes
and it was such a profound moment though
Rich it really was like I remember
I didn't understand about Sports
Nutrition or anything like I can
remember eating like um sugar do you
know that the sugar session packs
because I had no nutrition and I started
to blow up like the last 5K obviously I
didn't understand about carbohydrates
glycogen I'm on this ramsion no heart
I've no electrolytes something nothing's
or anything nothing whatsoever or any
coach or any heart rate monitor or any
sense of like how to train for something
like this or how to execute on that
nothing it was literally sheer force of
will and power like I remember in my
head I knew that's the record I need to
hold that split to beat that record and
all I did was just pound and I just used
brute power and strength and a mental
strength to get me through it and I kept
remembering like the police officers and
then this was a very big motivator for
me like when the prison officers or
sorry the police officers when they said
like you never look out the window
you're never going to see us again
people thinking I was a piece of [ __ ] so
when I was on that rivet and like you
get to a point where you're in so much
pain I I just can't remember like these
memories kept coming back to the form
and I was like I'm not a piece of [ __ ]
I'm not a loser I can achieve something
my life and it drove me and I remember
to get into that last 5K and I didn't
really understand because I was doing
all these circus stuff for myself I
never really understood what it was like
to blow up like when you ran out of
energy I'd never had this sensation for
and I remember Darren said to one of the
prisoners go and get him some sugar and
I was literally eating sugar at these
sachets and it got me to the end and
when I finished that record and I broke
it by seven minutes I was on that mat in
that gym and honestly
it really became clear to me then that
it was never about money
I made the attachment as a kid to
success and money it was never about
that
I just wanted to be successful at
something and I attached that to money
when I realized at that moment on that J
in that on that gym mat after just
finishing that record how it made me
feel like no one had ever done what I
had just done in that moment and I was
the best in the United Kingdom at that
and I just set a British record that
stood for like six years before I even
tried to break it and I felt incredible
and then for that moment I knew I would
use my body as a vehicle and that would
be the thing to get me out of this place
I started going down the library I
started getting books about Sports
Nutrition training Darren and and I know
you've had him on your podcast form we
spoke about him before we we started
this podcast but Lance Armstrong had a
profound impact over me like really did
I didn't even know what sort of like I
heard the Tour de France I didn't know
what it was and Darren bought me in his
autobiography it's not about the bike
Darren printed me off quotes and he
sticked me in front of the round machine
about quitting last forever pains
temporary I may I used to train and I'd
read them and they would literally you
can imagine moving up and down the slide
I'm just really in these quotes and then
I started watching the Tour de France
whilst I was in prison I started having
this awareness of cycling and tour and
Lance was still riding and I went on
this journey and Darren started bringing
me more and more books of all these
athletes and I remember like reading
these autobiographies and all of the
characteristics that I had
like from a kid
these group of people had as well but
the only people I saw like me were
criminals I never saw people that did
other things other than people that did
crime but you're identifying you're
you're finding your sensibility in the
stories of all of these athletes you're
like that's how I think that's how I
approach the problems that I've had
that's you know my mindset is like that
mindset like you're able to see like
you're you're finding like kinship in
all of these people yes yeah yeah and
and it and it opened up my eyes like
every time I broke a record on that rare
machine and within like 18 months I set
three world records and eight British
records I I basically had the Full House
nearly I did all right Marathon by seven
minutes so what what like 2 30 or
something like that what is it what are
we talking about it was too too Fair E7
237 and then I broke the world and
British record for a hundred thousand
meters which was six and a half hours
and then I set the British record for
half marathon which is why 115 or 114 it
might have been 10K I set that I set the
cut I set the kilometer records I set
the world record for the most distance
Road in 24 hours which was 163 miles and
then the longest continuous road which
was just shy of 48 Hours Non-Stop and
this is what year is this in 2011 2010
2011 it was
ah wasn't that long ago it really wasn't
do any of those records still stand well
it was quite funny because when I when I
broke the most amount of distance rate
in 24 hours
by a coincidence someone else was
training for it he was uh he was at
Southampton University
and Darren come and said like I
literally set the record and Damon said
someone's trying to break this next week
and I was like wow really and he's like
yeah he printed because I had no access
to the internet starring printed all his
stuff off and showed me it and brought
it to myself
like imagine he beats it I've only just
said it and I I smashed it I bro I broke
the last one by 13 miles so when I was
aware of it obviously you're talking to
other prisoners and I was saying oh this
guy's doing it and then he was doing it
I remember he started on a Friday so
Saturday morning doors unlock prison
doors like you're allowed to come out
for Association get straight on the
phone and I found out my cousin so he
had like a live link guy that was doing
the cameras and stuff watching him do it
so my cousin's feeding me what he's
where he's at so he he was on he was on
Pace with me up until like
20 hours 90 and a half hours
and mushroom clouded and blew up and my
cousin said oh he's cracked he's cracked
he's cracked and I was so relieved and I
thought oh wow like at least I'll keep
the record for a bit
and then I found out a couple years
after that a guy at Harvard University
he broke it and you know he broke it 12
meters
it was the most most meters in 24 hours
I I it was something like I wrote a
hundred a hundred and um it was it was
163 miles it was 12 meters it was
literally a stroke on a ram machine it
was one stroke after 24 hours does he
know that you like the circumstances
under which you set the record
no because you know when we put the
records on when we when we said where I
was we never said prison it was just
always Nottingham right I think we
talked about this last time yeah like I
wanted to know like how does it show up
on the printer yeah it just comes up as
Nottingham Circle because I did it in a
privately run prison so they didn't put
down I did it in prison it was just that
that but your story is out yeah he's out
now and I obviously when I got released
from prison I Googled the kid and I saw
all the pictures of when he was doing he
had massive Gatorade and he had fans
everywhere and I was like in this tiny
little prison gym with a tiny little fan
with nothing there was no stimulization
around me whatsoever in this rare
machine and the white wall behind it
right but yeah he broke it by like 12
meters but the world records have all
gone
but most of the British records still
stand yeah that's an unbelievable man
um I want to talk about Darren a little
bit I mean this this guy you know
changed your life and in ways you can't
even comprehend I mean it's unbelievable
and he's
super impressive in so many ways like
this guy rode his bike from Norway to
Malta right like he's done some epic
[ __ ] himself and I'm trying to remember
like I've got a bunch of friends in
Malta is he Maltese no no no no no he's
from the UK he is from the UK like I
think when there was a guy who swam from
Sicily to Malta a couple years ago did
Darren help crew for him I I seem to
remember stories from my friends in
Malta who were familiar with Darren
maybe because of the bike ride but
anyway
um I mean he's he's a remarkable man
guys unbelievable he's he is one of the
most thoughtful compassionate human
beings I've ever met like this
but my story is like extreme
but like when he was a prison officer
he's not anymore he's gone now to work
for a charity outside of prison that
helps with prison reform and helps stop
people from getting into prison as well
but when he was in prison the amount of
people that interact with him that
change their lives he was a one-man
Rehabilitation machine genuinely like it
was remarkable even to a degree one day
there was a prisoner of mental health
problems
wanted to attack him
this doesn't happen in prison
prisoners stopped that prisoner
attacking him that does not happen right
that is a big No-No if if a prisoner
wants to attack a prison officer you
know everyone would step out like no
one's stepping in and then fighting the
prisoners to stop the prison officer
getting up but that's the impact he had
over so many people like the respect
like within the prison he worked once I
got released I went back to prison I
couldn't believe what he'd done like he
he created his own gym within the prison
and there was like pictures of me and
him every prisoner that he ever worked
with that he he helped with
Rehabilitation when I got out and got
jobs set up their own gym chains it's
incredible professional fighters there's
another guy in there called K Musa
that's an MMA UFC fighter an MMA fighter
um can we change his life around right
and Darren Darren was was the Catalyst
for a lot of this change a lot of people
come out got jobs never went back to
prison all because he interacted with
him he is an amazing man and when when
we used to sit in the gym together it
went past that me and his me and his
room relationship went past the point it
wasn't just performance and rhyme
records like I used to sit with him in
the gym and he would talk about his
family and his kids and he'd open up to
me and this was like this does not
happen right prison guards are never
going to tell you about their personal
life right and since I've been out I've
met he's I've met his daughter I've met
his wife he's coming he's come out to
France with me he's like we've he's been
to near all of my races like we've been
fools she spawned with each other
disconnected but not even my own charity
like he was a trustee on that it's
honestly like he means so much to me and
he was the first male positive role
model I ever had in my life and I was 26
years old I never had anyone in my life
like a male that wasn't in my life for
uh like other than my mate that died
that there wasn't a vested interest
there wasn't something they were getting
out of it they weren't just there
because they fought a lot of you they
were there because there was something
that might have been you helping to make
money or whatever it was but Darren was
there purely because he wanted me to
succeed there was no money there was no
nothing and even when I wrote my book
obviously you sit there and I sat there
with a Ghostwriter
and I remember like I could tell
sometimes I'm telling him these stories
and we're talking about things and he
would look at me and I go yeah and he's
writing down and then he said would it
be possible to meet Darren I said I can
ask him Darren said yeah of course he
went up to Nottingham and he was with
Darren and obviously like I could tell
you this story I could tell all these
stories and people go and go he's not
telling the truth but obviously Darren's
then verifying it because Darren's the
other side of the defense like Damon was
on the other side perceiving it from his
perspective it's the same story
what he couldn't understand the ghost
writer was why Darren did it because
there was no money involved there's no
accolades like he wasn't getting
anything out of it I'm a guy serving two
life sentences in prison like he's not
getting anything out of that like coming
on his day off which he was not being
paid to sit with me on an exercise bike
for 24 hours behind me of a bandana run
coaching me through sitting on this Ram
machine because rich I had never done
that an ultra endurance event before up
to this point like I had to keep my body
awake for 24 hours on an on a ram
machine on a pace to set a record Darren
had like been to like um Greenland he'd
done Expeditions he'd done Ultra
endurance event like walks hikes
Mountain climbs he understood the
process of what the body goes through I
didn't so I remember being on that Ram
machine four o'clock in the morning my
body wants to go to sleep screaming for
me to sleep so now I'm having to fight
an urge that's like wired into my brain
and I remember Darren said I promise you
whether the storm
six o'clock seven o'clock your body snap
back out of it and you'll be fine and
you'll feel a million times better and I
said please just don't talk to me then
and he and he said I won't talk to you
but just just keep remembering in a few
hours your body will come back out that
cycle of wanting to sleep and you'll
feel fine like someone press the light
switch seven o'clock bang I was up I was
wide awake in that round machine I
weathered the storm I went all over in
and when I got to like one o'clock like
half one I set the world record and
Darren said now you just gotta [ __ ]
drop the hammer and go as hard as you
can and put as much time as you can into
into that record and that's why I broke
it by the distance I end up breaking it
by sure he had experience he understood
these things and then you can't a back
to the spirituality thing like you know
the idea that this guy gets put in your
path right and you have this innate
facility for this type of endeavor I
mean what are the chances of that yeah I
think it's energy as well like Darren
Darren saw that I was a man that like
wanted to turn my life friend and had
another Talent he believed that Talent
could help me change my life and he
supported it and he facilitated it and
like I said like without him there'd be
no me sure he's the Catalyst you're like
the pilot program then your picture ends
up on the wall in the gym that then ends
up with a lot more equipment and you
become the the lighthouse like the other
people who are coming in Darren can tell
that story they can look at you and then
with that that seed of belief can start
to germinate like oh that guy did it
like there is a path forward here if I
you know listen to this guy and allow
myself to be mentored and start
contemplating a different way of being
yeah like I I got burnishing rich I I
never really realized the impact that my
life would have over other people I
genuinely didn't like I'm me I don't I'm
not special I'm just who I am I do what
I do I've got character flaws everyone
has like no one's perfect I know I've
got a great awareness of my own life and
I think sometimes people get lost on
that and they think they put you up on a
pedestal and they think you're perfect
and I'm really really not like I'd get
the way I am allowed me to do what I did
years ago other people wouldn't want to
live the life that I live like some
people might think you ever get lonely
and stuff like that and I'll never ever
do I love being on my own I love
spending time on my own I love doing
things on my own I do rides and runs and
I just like being on my own I know a lot
of people can't deal with that and they
struggle but that helped me when I was
in that situation on that round machine
doing what I did being in that
segregation cell that's what's got me
through my life and that's what makes me
who I am
um but I never realized the the sort of
the impact that mine and Darren's
journey and the way it's sort of
inspired people not just even in similar
like similar situations as me like I
remember
a few it's quite it's quite a few years
ago I received an email right from a
woman and maybe honestly like even now
like I remember like I never thought
about what the story I'm about to tell
you I I wouldn't even compute that would
be possible
so this woman was raped
he never got caught we did it it was a
stranger rate and she read my book and
she sent me this email and she said in
the book
the person that did that to me was never
caught
and she said I really hope like you he
changed his life and he never did it
again and she said that's what I took
out of your story that if you managed to
do it maybe he changed his life and he
never did that again to anyone else
and I'm like how like I never thought
for a moment like maybe some kids that
were involved in gangs or but you read
these these these stories sometimes from
people and and that that one stood out
but the amount of mums that have
messaged me where their sons are in
prison and and it sort of changed their
their mindset on what's possible like
you can achieve things with your life
you can turn your life around you can be
positive and a Beacon of Hope and it
isn't the end just because you make one
bad decision in your life you can always
come back from it and Achieve something
with your life
um and if that means you're just not
wasting your life and having belief in
yourself a little bit more like I never
thought for a moment that that my life
or minor damage journey and story
together with that sort of positive
impact in the world but I do think that
when I did have that realization it
becomes your duty then to sort of to to
help lift people up like I've said you
before that's my definition of what
life's about we're only on this planet
for such a brief moment of time I want
other people to live a happy healthy
lifestyle where they believe in
themselves and they've got confidence in
themselves and they make the most of the
short amount of time that they've got on
this Earth yes it's a duty but it's also
the thing that gives you the most Joy
like we started this conversation with
you sharing stories about being with
these kids over the last two days and
and how much that lights you up so you
know it's It's Curious like you on some
level
you know are carrying on Darren's Legacy
in this living a men's way like you all
took pot shots at you know the criminal
who who stole a Christmas presents and
all of that but in truth like the crimes
that you perpetrated had Downstream
negative implications on a lot of
people's lives right so part of
resurrecting yourself and creating A New
Path is to make peace with the past and
try to the extent that you're capable of
making you know making things right
right and so mentoring these kids your
foundation these initiatives that's all
part and parcel of that and what's
Curious is is how much those are the
things that actually make you the
happiest and and give your life meaning
and and kind of direct you in this
purposeful way yeah like even even
yesterday that being around those kids
and seeing the impact and like because
of my actions and the way I because
again I think in life you learn from
every every experience when sometimes I
embrace when negative things happen
because they do they happen to all of us
like bad bad situations and like things
happen you haven't got control over them
and you can perceive them as a negative
but I've always used it as fuel like to
me it fuels me I learn I take a learning
from everything bad people come to my
life I learn from it I I yeah it's not
been a great experience but I'm going to
turn this down to a positive and use it
as fuel I use the fact that all those
years when I was put in prison by my own
doing like bad life choices but I accept
responsibility for my own actions I put
myself in that situation by doing what I
did breaking the law but all of this all
of this energy that I've gathered over
the years and for the experience and
turning it into a positive it's led to
like now me being outer Department
initiative that works with thousands of
kids across the UK and then they look at
you as a role model and when I was in
that school yesterday like they hang off
every word that you say they're so
malleable
and for me to be in a position in my
life now where sort of you can get
massive Brands behind me that will
facilitate and help me drive that agenda
message like it is incredible and it is
amazing and it's the greatest
achievement I've ever done in my life
like the records everything don't get me
wrong the records have facilitated the
movement because without the story there
would be no big Brands coming in and
helping me do this stuff but to me that
that is that is legacy and it it took me
so long to understand that Legacy to me
like I said is about helping people
realize their own potential and when I'm
dead because that person's had an
interaction with me or something I've
been part of that's positive their life
is better sure it's not your name on a
building no it's the manner in which the
lives that you impacted are then living
their lives and yes you know on a higher
on a higher plane and passing that on to
Future generations and that's truly how
you become immortal right like the
downstream impact of of positive lives
altered because of your your choice to
try to make an impact on young people
yeah it's crazy I mean it's really a
beautiful thing there's gaps in the
story that we've told I mean ultimately
you you get paroled you get out you end
up going down to the London Rowing Club
and we kind of told a little bit of that
story last time you find your way into
Iron Man and you know kind of are still
continuing to participate as far as the
brands you've been with Nike now for a
long time right five years five years
yeah and you've got I think you've got
your Cervelo is your bike sponsor you
have Volvo dude
but you know with with everyone that
I've worked with they've all like bought
into what I'm doing and they've all
facilitated me continuing that work like
Nike put a huge investment into open
doors and they've supported me a hundred
it's not about you being on Podium
that's about you carrying on this
message and living a certain lifestyle
and you know kind of walking your talk
yeah but you still like we we were
texting earlier and you're like I'm I
I'm just finished my training like what
are you are you training now for
anything yeah so so next summer I want
to take part in a race called the Race
Across France which is a bike race
um I want to go to win it uh I want to
try to break the record which is four
days and 22 hours it says 2 600
kilometers uh with 33 000 meters of
climbing wow but most the most important
thing as an hour I'm a fellow vegan yeah
I want to demonstrate you can do that
event plant-based so I've been vegan now
for two years and obviously we're
probably going to preach to the
converted now but performance wise I'm
39 years old I'm in the best shape I've
ever been in I've had no major injuries
I don't get sick that much I recover
great power numbers on the bike are the
best they've ever been uh did an ultra
endurance bike race a couple weeks ago
to tour de Mont Blanc like I burnt 12
000 calories of energy in 13 hours
absolutely fine and I want to
demonstrate that you are able to compete
and perform to a higher level on a on a
plant-based diet so that's my big goal
for next June they haven't fixed the
date yet when the start of it but you
start from the south of France and you
basically go like West's up to like
Calais you go like diagonally across the
country and then actually go through
Provence move on to all the Alps and
then slingshot across the country to the
ocean to the coast and you go up towards
that Kelly wow so you're taking the hard
route if you're going west yeah like
what and then North
West you go yeah so you start down in
South France go through Provence and
then you kind of like go around the
hardest mountains there and then go into
the high mountain Alps and then Knights
go diagonally across the country so it's
33 so you're climbing Mount Everest four
times wow in night if it takes me five
days it takes you five days but that's
that's the plan I'd like to to beat the
record of four days in 22 hours nice and
uh walk me through the decision to begin
this vegan Journey
well when I was only last time I was I
was I was a meat eater never really even
I never even processed everything I'm a
vegan by the way we didn't even I have
nothing to do with this no you have
nothing to do with it you have actually
but yeah never never in my mind never I
was never really conscious of the world
in that regards very performance driven
Rowan then Iron Man was in that
environment where like a lot of coaches
would probably recommend that you don't
like saying there's not that many
world-class vegan athletes but again it
was never even my mind like I never even
had the conversation about doing it
moved to France probably the worst
country if you wanted to become vegan in
the mountains
and the journey and the story and the
way it worked out was I'm out there like
I said in June 2020 after covered when
the first lockdowns were hitting
everyone and there was a little Gap
where we could travel a bit so I'm out
there I was on my own and there's a
little like there's a little like Place
well going which is sunset in the
mountains and it's beautiful it just
drops behind this Lake
anyway go up there every night and there
was an equestrian center and next to
your question strength Center there was
like these Stables I now saw these like
these horses walking around four horses
and I went up one night and the horses
up come over I went up the next night
took a little bag of carrots and apples
fed them did it again the next night
next night next night instinctively the
minute I started going up there the
horses would recognize me straight away
to the degree that when a couple of
friends come out I said watch this so
they didn't believe me so literally the
minute I got out the car and I walked up
to like this like field these horses
obviously sense and they come they come
over my mate was like that is
unbelievable and I come up and I'm
stroking the horse's nose and stuff
and it may like I had never in my life
ever grown up around animals like I I
never like other than a dog or a cat
like I've never been in nature never
really been exposed to it whenever I
went on holiday it was always to cities
or when I lived in the south of Spain or
like I'd never been in like profound
strong powerful nature in the outdoors
I've never experienced that as a kid I
never experienced as an adult to to I
was like my late 30s
and then one night I'm there there's
this horse
and I'm looking into the horse's eyes
and I had this connection with this
horse and I obviously at this point
realized the horse was sent to me all
the horses were sent to me
and I felt like a hypocrite and I didn't
like seeing cows and sheep behind
electric fences when I watched like the
cattle trucks go in and their little
noses poking out the holes in the cattle
tracks and it profoundly affected me and
it reminded me of being in prison it's
the only way I can really explain it and
I just didn't like how it made me feel
and that night with that horse when I
was looking into the horse's eyes I just
made the decision that night I would
never eat or drink consume any animal
products ever again
and I didn't the only thing I found
tough so it really was like a lightning
bolt a hundred percent 100 like the only
thing that was challenging afterwards I
didn't miss any food groups it was the
force of habit of like when you go into
a coffee shop
deliberately saying I don't want milk in
my coffee but like Ireland took that on
I don't eat honey like I went to the
full extreme I didn't even realize there
was levels of veganism it was only like
so like I went horse riding once never
do it again I'd never ride a horse again
because I didn't like I I did it once
before I went vegan but then I didn't
like the exploitation of sitting on a
horse and it to me like the horses I saw
they looked like they were sedated and I
just didn't like it and I thought I'm
never doing that again so I did it once
never again but I went to the full
extreme veganism I Don't Preach to
people like we go out for dinner
sometimes and people like look and go oh
do you mind if I have ham and stuff and
I go look cool it's your body you have
to make your own choices and decisions I
make my decisions based on my reasoning
um this is why I did it it's up to you
whether you do it I don't force it on
other people but for me it was more of a
moral issue and I didn't like how it
made me feel being around those animals
and and the fact that even when I go
walking and stuff like when you're in
the mountains and you're in such
powerful found strong nature and like
you're seeing butterflies flying around
like how like all these creatures have
evolved to inhabit the same Planet as we
are right now and I I look at the fish
in the water and stuff and it it changes
you so so profoundly I know I keep
saying that word but it really really
did
McAvoy going vegan was not on my 2020
bingo card you know like it's CR it's
like
it's so funny I could have never
anticipated like hearing a monologue
like that coming from you like not just
vegan like compassionate vegan like
doing it for the animals and and being
like pretty hardcore about it yeah but I
didn't realize there was levels I've
learned this afterwards like when you
meet certain vegans like I've been in
situations before where like I've had an
acai Bowl and they brought Hannah said
not eating it can you take it back I
don't have honey and then I'm with my
vegan we don't eat honey I said but you
do oh yeah but I do I didn't realize
there was levels of this stuff like how
I just thought when you was a vegan
that's it like you don't have leather
seats in your car you don't so I went
like the whole extreme other version I
even revolver I said I need all the
leather seats taken out my car oh
there's more levels
the highest well I mean there are some
that would argue that that it's your
obligation to get a vasectomy okay yeah
like we can go how far do you want to go
John I didn't realize exactly I thought
I was at the top level I didn't realize
there was another one past that well
also like all the consumer choices that
you make every single day yeah
um it's not just food but you know it's
obvious clothing is an obvious example
but you know how what are the downstream
you know consequences of a certain
product like like you buy a garment and
it's not leather but it was made in a
factory overseas where toxic dyes end up
in the waterways the you know the in the
rivers and that poisons the fish right
so we all like none of us walk the earth
harm free or cruelty free we all
participate because we're living
breathing animals and we need to consume
certain things so it's a question of you
know how you know how far you kind of
telescope that out yeah I didn't but it
gets you but it makes you more conscious
like oh the the decisions that you make
and you know how you exercise your
purchasing power do you have you know
those those implications may be subtle
and they may be invisible to you but
still they're real yeah yeah yeah so
there's always a learning experience
learning about how things are processed
made designed where they're coming from
the implications it's happened far
greater yeah than what you're just
physically putting into your body
it's interesting your experience with
this is sort of the inverse of mine
because I got into it
initially due to vanity and health
concerns like I didn't like being a fat
slob I didn't like how I looked I didn't
like how I felt and then going vegan
plant-based resolved that for me but now
I've been doing it for it's been 15
years at this point and now the Animal
Welfare piece and the environmental
piece are you know probably more
important to me than the health piece
and that's just an evolution you know
and I think when people make these
healthy lifestyle changes
certain in-groups are very quick to
judge them and I think that that's
really wrong-headed like you have
everybody has to you know find their way
to a new thing and be encouraged to
continue their learning experience with
it yeah most definitely yeah when you
look back on all of this do you have
like what is the emotional Resonance of
it like is it gratitude for everything
that has happened are there regrets is
there any lingering feelings of guilt or
shame associated with it like how do you
yeah it's a complex one like regret do I
have regret yes I have regret in regards
of like the the ramifications of my
actions years ago affected other
people's lives but like then the journey
that I've been on for myself I don't
regret things I've done it it's a it's a
it's a complex thing I don't I think you
learn from everything but I obviously
understand my story my life's been
extreme where it wasn't just about me my
my actions had a negative impact on
other people's lives I've got a
tremendous amount of gratitude for the
people that Sports brought into my life
again this is something that I didn't
really consciously think about I used to
think it was everything was like
performance being fast breaking records
being quick running marathons and stuff
like that but what I've realized over my
life that the power of sports about the
power of the people it's brought into my
life because it was Darren that changed
my life and since I got out who you met
last time when it come on the podcast it
was sitting with me Terry these people
massively changed my life
um and I've had incredible life
experiences I've met incredible people
along the journey through Sport and it's
not the sport itself it's not because
I've run really quick on if it's the
people it's bought in but gratitude is
is is is up there as the biggest thing
I've probably got out of the my life
experience I've been appreciative of the
fact that I was very fortunate to come
across individuals at certain points in
my life that have led me to having the
life I've got today but yeah the regret
thing yeah I I regret what I did because
it wasn't just about me it wasn't like I
[ __ ] my own life up and I it didn't
have any real ramifications in other
people's lives so I regret the fact that
by my negative behavior that impacted
other people's lives but I don't regret
going to prison and if you I said this
in the last podcast if honestly if you
said to me now you go back to being 22
years old and I can let you out there I
would want to go through that Journey
again I would I would want to spend the
10 years in there because I learned so
much about myself about life at Grammy
and awareness of life
um and I've got a lot of life lessons
out of that and and that's helped me be
the person I am today so I needed to go
through that journey I just regret that
the fact that those that behavior
affected us but you've made peace with
who that person was at that time yeah
because I think I've heard you say in
other podcasts that you've done maybe
you know in the last year or two you're
telling a story and you're like I'm so
ashamed of you know this like that that
I was this person or whatever like there
were hints of like like you feeling like
like suddenly you're tightening up
because you got to tell a story about
something that you did that yeah it
still brings that not what I said you
only run about when I was 12 years old
watching that film about my uncle like
that I feel I do feel embarrassed like I
feel embarrassed I get I was a young kid
but like to say that I would watch an
individual like that and watch a film
like that and that would motivate and
inspire me as the person I am today
right it feels so alien from who I am
and what I stand for as a person today
that I do feel embarrassed by it like I
look how on Earth would I even have that
thought process again I was 12 years old
but it still does make me feel like that
because my life is so profoundly but you
can give that 12 year old a break right
you can you know you can give it and and
that was a an important moment in in the
assembly of the person that you are
today yes yeah I mean I guess what I'm
getting at is I did hear like like some
sense of still like you know whinging
over like talking about who you were as
that young person and then in that like
I see or I hear an opportunity for you
for a little bit of self-love
exploration right can you feel
compassion for that young John who you
know came up in certain circumstances
where the decisions that you made were
almost foregone conclusions all along
the way yeah and it also gives me a
great self-awareness and and also it's
given me great skills where like I can
put myself in the position of other
people at that age
I
can sit there with them and I totally
get even as Extreme as it is like going
back to what we're speaking about with
the guys that we commit to the terrorism
like as Extreme as it is and some you
you do not agree with what they've done
you do understand how they've got to
that point because you was once very
similar to that and you you understand
how they've got to that position in
their minds of thinking a certain way
because you've also been that sort of
person and I I've been able to come out
of that and have that awareness of that
situation and and sort of better my life
so there is a way out even if you could
be the most hateful resentful bitter
Twisted person in the world but you can
always find ways out of that there is
there is another path
but you are somebody who has such a deep
facility for mental toughness like your
mental game is so off the charts right
so in terms of empowering somebody else
who feels stuck like your your message
really is look at my life all these
things happen and I still was able to
change how I was living and if I can do
it certainly anybody can do it
the retort to that would be well you're
this unbelievably gifted athlete or you
have you know a mental strength that is
superhuman so what am I supposed to do
I don't I don't think it is superhuman I
don't think it's too human like I I I
the way I process me as a person in this
universe and in this world is just that
I'm like everyone else and I think a lot
of it's been patience time being open
susceptible to different events
um when I went for that journey of
wanting something different from my life
being open to different things
interacting with different groups of
people not being so sort of like
blinkered into one thing and putting
myself out there and opening up myself
to new experiences which brought these
amazing people into my life that shaped
me that gave me advice and being more
open-minded because probably years ago I
say probably I was I was very
close-minded it was one track minded
that was it there was nothing else it
was just that one thing but you had this
willingness to challenge yourself like
I'm gonna stay in solitary or you know
I'm going to prove to myself that I'm
stronger physically and and mentally
than anybody else
and that would stem back from childhood
but that comes from anger yeah that was
that was driven that's an event that was
very negative emotions which again
retrospectively when I look back on that
situation like to to that could have
quite easily broken me that he could
have done I could have gone to that
situation and come out with and the
Litany of mental health problems by
doing that to myself like isolate myself
having very limited human contact for
that period of time but rich I wouldn't
say how many different terminals it was
just that when I went for that journey
of like of processing everything that
had gone on in my life my friend dying
it was just the fact that I was more
susceptible and I opened up my eyes more
to stuff and the moment I did that and
changed that mindset and let people come
into my life and trusted people which
are something that I really struggled
with because I was always brought up not
to trust people being very distrusted in
why someone wanted to associate and be
with you and be close to you but when I
went for that journey of like having
this realization that like a short life
isn't being more open that all of these
incredible people come into my life
which shaped my life that showed me a
different way of living and it and it
opened up my eyes to a different way of
living and and the advice that they give
me and stuff changed my life profoundly
when we look at pre this is the last
thing I want to talk about which is
prison reform uh this is really close to
your heart for obvious reasons you've
been to 10 Downing Street you talk about
this all the time
when you look at incarceration there's
really three pillars to justify it it's
like we need to punish people punitive
we need it needs to be it needs to
prevent crime from happening right
preventative and then it's meant to be
rehabilitative and I feel like all of
the energy is around punitive and then
you know the fact that like crimes
aren't committed while people are
incarcerated is sort of just a side
benefit of that but when it comes to
Rehabilitation that's at best given lip
service these checks that you know these
boxes that are getting checked that we
talked about before like in your mind
what is the path towards truly
rehabilitating
people who are incarcerated or what
changes would you make in the system to
make it achieve that goal of turning
people out who can become productive
members of society
it's a very complex issue
um like from my experience of what I've
seen and stuff I've seen in the
background when when I've gone and sort
of spoken to professors and I've got him
MPS members of parliament youth Justice
secretary was incredible in the UK
called Dr Philip Lee she was a doctor
general practitioner really saw the
emphasis on sport so you must remember a
lot of people in prison have had really
bad experiences of the education system
before they most of them have been
excluded from school gone into pupil
referral units this is in the UK but
it'd be quite similar in America I would
imagine so they get they get they get
chucked out of school and there's a
pipeline a clear pipeline so there was
86 000 men in prison in the UK 56 000 of
them were excluded from school so you
statistically you're going to prison
nearly all of them and we was having
this conversation about the reform of
the system so he put a lot of emphasis
on sport
because of the life skills that sport
could teach them and he wanted to sort
of re-change this this whole push now
they need to be educated yes but to Fred
education and through physical activity
and through sport because a lot of young
people a lot of people in prison if you
said to them what's the most important
thing they would pick
Foods
gym visits now if you can tie up an
educational thread through the physical
activity piece that's not all of them
becoming at personal trainers is is
spreading in the learnings that they can
learn through Sport and tie in some
Educational Learning education where
they can get jobs when they get released
in prison I think that would
fundamentally change a lot of people's
lives in prison from my experience and I
feel like in the UK and I'm not just
saying this because I'm on your podcast
but I feel like my story is definitely
had a positive impact over that
narrative because MPS people in
positions of authority empowering the
MOJ like they can look up my story and
obviously because it's it's the bells
and whistles it's it's definitely
encourages movement to take place and a
privatization to be put over people's
physical well-being mental well-being in
prisons and wrapping that up within an
educational learning thread but the
challenge is to get people beyond the
bells and whistles of your story to
learn that this is possible for anybody
not the facts of your experience but you
know some level of Rehabilitation and
you know the sports piece
look it's important to be physically fit
and all of that but it's really the
self-esteem it's a self-esteem building
thing it's a thing where you can give
people that level of agency and get them
invested in themselves because when you
start looking after yourself physically
that ends up spilling obviously into all
these other areas of your life yeah most
definitely and if you spoke to most
prison offices in the UK and
correctional offices in America I have
quite a lot of prison officers in
America message me and like my book
somehow found its way into the
correctional system in America oh it did
that's cool yeah there was a prison
officer um Bobby's name is from Boston
and um he's retired now so I'll tell you
the story but you can't I didn't realize
this you can't take books hardback books
into prison so we used to take the front
cover or the back cover of my book off
so it was just pages and take them in
and prisoners and he sent me some
pictures a couple weeks ago I have
prisoners that have been released from
Boston in the prison Correction Facility
it's amazing mate absolutely amazing and
they read my book in prison in America
wow and they've and they've got out and
he said it's really been a catalyst for
one of the prisoners turning his life
around and using sport physical activity
but I do think it can be a fundamental
pillar of Rehabilitation because people
are passionate about it they're
passionate about Fitness in prisons they
really are like the gym is one of the
most popular things you you could want
to do in prison and even prison officers
never want to take Jim away from
prisoners because they understand the
benefits it has over them and the fact
that when they do do it violence goes up
into prison you've got all this
testosterone anger hatred where there's
an outlet in the prison gym now again if
you can tie that into a learning piece
which there are a lot of sports
organizations now going in definitely in
the UK definitely the The Tide is really
turn right when I was in prison 10 years
ago I got released 10 years in September
ago like it wasn't even a fraction of
like now what's going on in the UK
prison system it's incredible like
Sebastian Vettel the the F1 driver was
in Felton young offenders
um a couple of months ago car workshop
um you've got professional football
players going in professional rugby
players going in professional football
clubs there's a massive initiative in
the UK now where football clubs are
twinning up with prisons and then the
clubs are going into the local prison
give providing Educational Learning and
then when the prisoners are getting out
they're giving them jobs at the football
clubs working and there's a groundsman
working in Hospitality stewardship so
there's massive shift that's gone on in
the UK which I'm really proud to have
been that's unbelievable I I I don't
think that that's what's happening in
the United States I mean if it is I'm
unaware of it and I would be happily
disabused of that notion but I think we
have a long way to go I feel like your
book would be well served to be you know
just sort of you know a big part of
every prison Library well yeah like when
when when first lockdown happened we
sent two and a half thousand copies of
my book to the young offenders estate so
that meant every person under the age of
21 in the UK got given a copy of my book
as a as a workshop like today it was all
part of a workbook clip so they
basically got given the book and then
like some prisons did like stuff where
like there was book reviews it was quite
interesting actually because the prison
officers were emailing me the book
reviews and I had to pick it was quite
fascinating I mean you really doubt
other kids in there perceive your story
but every child in that prison under the
age 21 got a copy of my book to read it
whilst they were basically on lockdown
because the whole prison system shut
down and again it was about trying to
teach them that even though they're in
that environment that there was things
that they could do like when I was in
that segregation cell doing the cell
workout reading books keeping myself
active act like my mind active and I
wanted that to be like sort of an
inspiration to them in that really bad
situation and that was where a lot of
the mums were messaging me saying my
sons read your book and also it's gone
filtered through because there's two or
a thousand of them were donated to the
prison that's gone through to prison
officers so then prison officers read
the journey and that's another really
important thing as well like a prison
officer going into work realizing
they're not there just to lock someone
up they're there to help change their
lives yeah and it's I mean that that
goes to this piece about Rehabilitation
if you can start with just the mindset
of the like being a prison guard is a
really hard job well I think in the UK
it has one of the highest rates of
mental health in all of them private
sector the same in the United States
yeah we would be the job site they're
stressed all day like you you imagine
going into an environment where you
don't know if you're going to get
attacked like you're you're inside all
day you literally got cameras point to
you the stress and pressure of people
screaming at you every day yeah it's got
to be really difficult you must get
insane emails though from from people
who are incarcerated or who have just
gotten out and these young people
through your website and stuff like that
like yeah a lot and it and it is very
humbling like sometimes when I read them
like again I I I'm not I don't see
myself as being anything special so when
you read an email if someone said I read
your book when I was in a when I was in
a segregation sale I read your book when
I was in a police whatever wherever they
were and it's been a catalyst for them
doing something with their lives coming
out working in a gym the amount of
people that again like started taking up
rowing right that is actually now in the
UK prison system There's an actual a
national indoor rowing League oh there
is
tracks directly back to you it's crazy
like there's actually a national indoor
around league so then you prisoners like
the British indoor rowing championships
there were prisoners in prison in the UK
racing people outside of prison life
even but they know it the people who are
one of those yeah
unbelievable like in Melbourne in prison
there was a prison in Australia and they
sent these pictures of these prisoners
into our own and the guys and I'm like
what the [ __ ] like it's incredible it's
incredible though like to think that and
I always send it to Darren I say look at
this and he was like wow and you think
we just started off around in a prison
gym and it's like it's just spread
everywhere and I there's there's
initiative that's out called boats not
bars where rowing clubs go into prisons
and they they teach young people to run
around machines or prisoners not just
kids on the age 21 and then when they go
through this this sort of Journey of
learning to indoor row they they
obviously using it to keep fit and then
some of them are getting into their
sentences and they can join the local
Rowing Club and some of the stories
there where I've seen where people got
released they become rowing instructors
and Rowing coaches it's very humbly Rich
wow and it's something I would never
ever ever take for granted and something
I'm tremendously proud of like again to
know that my life has aided them to see
the light and they're living the best
life they can live and they're not in
prison and they're free and they have
they're content that whatever it is
they're doing now they're content but
because they've interacted with my life
story or me as a person they are now
doing something that they're at peace
with and they and they're in a good
place and they're not just rotten in a
cage not living to their potential and
the legacy of that and what they will
then pass down I mean that's a really
profound thing oh mate yeah it's
something that like again I'm very
appreciative of and I've got a
tremendous amount of gratitude for yeah
when your head hits the pillow at night
just think about that if you've had a
hard day yeah
all right so 10 Downing Street you get
to talk to all these professional
footballers and all kinds of cool stuff
but come on man Idris Elba you got to
tell me what's going on there yeah just
I yeah they they asked me to be part of
a TV program I could also do a lot of
stuff if I'm honest and I say no to
nearly 99 of it so I will not do
anything with what we've just spoke
about that would do any detrimental
damage to that so anything that wants to
undermine it in any way that who I am as
a person will not do it doesn't matter
how much money people want to track at
me to do it it has to be to my core
beliefs
um and like I said like stuff like TV
programs radio stuff like magazines
newspaper articles unless it fits in
with what I'm doing and the message I
want to spread I say no and sometimes
you say no and they think you're saying
no because they think you want more
money and it isn't the money I don't
care how much they offer it's about the
offense city of who I am as a person
that come in and they said would you
like to be part of this this show and I
was like what is it about
and then they explained about the kids
that were on this journey of learning to
become boxers and using the power of
sport to help show them or teach them
about life skills and giving them
opportunities and did I want to be one
of the mentors and I said yeah I'll do
it and then um yeah I decided to do it
and it was a it was a very interesting
TV show to be part of it was uh I've
never been on TV before like I've never
done anything like that it's a
completely different alien world to me
and actually I think I was actually
quite surprised because obviously
because I had no backlog of anything
they kind of thought that like I'd
imagine they must have thought he might
go on and he just might not be that good
and then when I did my day
they were actually like the guy that was
doing like word count and stuff and how
much because he was just me speaking all
day and he was like you're really good
at this stuff and then have you ever
have you done a lot of it and I was like
nah this is the first time and he's like
you definitely need to do more but then
we were talking about it and I said
actually I'll get asked to do a lot of
stuff and I say no to everything and he
said that is 100 the right decision
don't ever sell yourself out and do
things that will go against what your
core beliefs are and and to sometimes
reach like the journey sometimes of like
I have found it frustrating when you're
trying to get a message out and then
you're getting given me like an
opportunity that you wouldn't take but
an opportunity to to sort of magnify
your message but then you know it will
do damage to you as a person and the
message you're trying to get out in the
long run so it's like short-term gains
over long-term gains and I've always
just played the long game in regards to
that stuff and I won't undermine my
credibility and what I stand for you
can't I mean it's all about that that's
all you it goes back to the beginning of
like your name right like that's all you
have like that that speech that you guys
a young person is actually true in that
regard like because of the residence
that you carry and the message that
you're trying to put out in the world
you have to be true to your word you've
got to walk your talk and you've got to
make sure that your actions are in total
alignment with your values because then
if that gets eroded then there's no
power behind the words that come out of
your mouth right most definitely like
probably the last since I've seen you
I probably had five film contracts put
in front of me yeah five different film
contracts I'm a little bit familiar with
some of that yeah yeah because we've
talked about that yeah yeah and like and
every single one
like they're not bad people but it's
just not the right it's not been right
and it's like no I'm not I'm not doing
it and I there's some of them that have
been really lucrative and I remember one
of them in particular I got and I was I
was looking at it and the people that
were helping me on my end was like
because I haven't got any sort of
awareness I don't understand that world
whatsoever it's completely alien to me
so I thought I better get some help
someone guiding me through it and they
were even surprised by how lucrative it
was for the first round and they said
I'm surmising no one knew but whoever
they've pitched this to must have been
greenlighted because they desperately
want you to sign that contract but it
wasn't right like I'm not going to erode
all the work that I've done in my life
like I'm not going I'm not willing to do
that and destroying my credibility just
because because I'm not interested in
Fame that doesn't interest me it doesn't
bother me whatsoever like red carpets
and stuff like that like I just want to
be happy living on the mountain with
sheep and cows and stuff like I'm good
like I don't I'm not doing it for that
reason if I feel like by getting the
right thing made that it's gonna I'm
amplify what I stand for and it's going
to people going to watch it and come out
and feel sort of inspired and feel like
I can do anything with my life or or not
maybe not pre-judge people so much and
what you're filming at the end of it
come out and go if I was in these
situation as a kid like not preaching
let them make their own decision but if
I if I was had that sort of environment
as a kid would I have done what he did
and make people maybe think a bit
differently as well but yeah like I say
I've said no to everybody everything
that's been put in front of me it's only
now there's there's a strong possibility
I will say yes because it's with the
right people and and I'm I'm part of the
creative process of making it and and
I've always adamantly said I will not
glorify that life like I don't want a
film that's like Goodfellas or anything
like a film like that that glorifies
that that negative toxic well now don't
get me wrong it's obviously a big part
of my life but I don't want to the
glorification of it I don't want it to
be like a Hollywood sort of crime film
and and and sort of the the really
important part of the story mine and
Darren's relationship gets watered down
and it and if that doesn't become the
essence of what the film's about yeah I
mean that's that is the movie that
relationship right everything else is
like fluff around that but you know look
these things happen when they're
supposed to with the people they're
supposed to happen with that I think the
best long-term you know strategy is to
continue to double down on your
integrity and you will know when it's
right yeah 100 yeah and I'm here to help
but anyway I can be of service you can
play me
not no behind the camera
um all right well we got to get you back
to the mountain so let's end this but
maybe you know a good way to kind of
take us out is with a little bit of
inspiration for that person who who
still feels stuck or is in a rut or
feels like they're settling in their lot
in life like how do we get that person
to step outside of their reality look at
it from a different perspective and and
perhaps start walking a different path
so again I can only go from my own
perspective of reality and the journey
that I've been on I would say open
yourself up to new experiences break old
habits
um I set myself this challenge every
week I like to experience something
different that's not doing something
massive it's doing tiny little things
interacting with a different human going
to a different place just experiencing
different things and being open-minded
to stuff and not so sort of blinkered
onto one thing and and sometimes in life
rich like it is hard it is but you can't
give up you've got a red belief you've
got to look at other people's lives and
and look at them and go if they've been
able to do that I'm I'm able to also do
it it's not jealousy it's not looking at
other people and thinking oh why have
they got that out having an open
positive mindset to things and people
like there's people that achieve things
in things that I don't really find
interesting but it motivates me because
I think they're living what they want to
do they've achieved what they want to
achieve and and it makes me realize that
I'm also able to do what I want to do
with my life but just being oh open to
to experiences and opportunities and
knowing that again some people say it's
quite morbid but we're all on a clock
and we haven't got that much time so
that I want to maximize every single day
I've got on this planet by being as
content as I can be in my existence and
that's what motivates me now so I would
say to everyone just remember recap
yourself when things get a little bit
hard about life just remember you're not
going to be here forever and just make
the most of the short time that you've
got and act on stuff don't put stuff off
to tomorrow to next week to the week
after that because those weeks might not
ever come and don't be that person at
the end where the doctor might say
you've only got a couple of months left
to live and you think I've not done
anything in my life Memento Mori yeah
Memento Mori here we are boom powerful
John McAvoy thanks man thank you
beautiful I appreciate it everybody
should pick up his book Redemption you
can get it on amazon.com in the US too
yeah
um and Amazon UK if you're over here and
anywhere else you want to direct people
your Instagram your Twitter all that
kind of stuff yeah go that I can yeah
it's uh John McAvoy too yes it from
Twitter yeah you know that more than I
do I was uh and then Instagram is I
think it's John mcavoy83 now Johnny Mac
83 is it I think I wrote it down here
let's make sure this I forgot I mean
we'll link it up but it's uh yeah Johnny
Johnny with no h j o n n y Mac 83 why
Johnny Mac 83
um all right man I appreciate it I'm I'm
your biggest fan and I'm here to support
you in any any way that I can I think
your journey in addition to just you
know being inspiring and inspiring
millions of people it's really your
commitment to service your advocacy your
alignment of your actions with your
values that that really is so impressive
and I think that the impact that you're
leaving will be felt for generations to
come so I just wish you well and win
means a lot thank you peace peace mate
plants
[Music]
foreign
[Music]